. Hallo Berlin, schön, dass ihr da seid, danke schön, vielen, vielen Dank, hebt euch noch ein bisschen Applaus auf für, er ist heute hier, hier ist Stefan Dieter! Dankeschön, dankeschön, ja, dankeschön, und wie könnte es anders sein, ich habe ihn euch mitgebracht, dass es kein Geringer als Florentin motherfucking will! Dankeschön! Dankeschön! Vielen, vielen Dank! Dankeschön! Und zusammen sind wir mit euch das Podcast UFO. Oder wie es im Backstage-Bereich steht, POFO. POFO, es steht auch jedes Mal anders und meistens sind wir auch der Podcast UFO einfach. Hat mir nicht sogar einmal, dass dann so ein Tontechniker zu uns hingekommen ist und meinte so, ja, ja, ich glaube auch, dass es da noch mehr gibt, als man in der Presse immer liest. Und ich mir so, ja, kann sein. Er meinte, wir reden über Ufos jetzt anderthalb Stunden. Ja genau, was wir gewohnt sind. Und ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, wir kommen ja in unterschiedlichen Zeiten immer zum Hotel auch an und es ist immer wieder ein bisschen weird und immer lustig herauszufinden, unter welchem Namen wir einstecken müssen. Weil meistens ist es Pufo oder Ufo und man fragt sich immer so rum. Manchmal ist auch der eine Podcast und der andere Ufo und beide sind unzufrieden damit, was sie geworden sind. Wer hat denn das bessere Zimmer unter uns, Pufo oder Band? Man weiss es nicht. Aber wir waren auch mal, Podcast Band. Ja, das war kurz die Phase, in der wir uns dachten, Podcast, wir will jemanden mehr hören. Musik machen wollen. Wir machen Musik, weil ich bin ja ein bisschen neidisch auf Stafford, muss ich sagen, weil der einzige unter uns ist, der mal eine erfolgreiche Musikkarriere hat. Na, erfolgreich? Wir sind in der ersten Runde rausgekommen. Wo sind die Biggie-Sack-Buh-Ultras? Das ist doch rauf. Ja, das ist doch rauf. Das dritte Reihe. Nicht ganz, ist es schwer gekommen. Lass uns alle Westerland singen jetzt, gleichzeitig, für Sarah Connor. Ja, lass uns Gema einfach direkt Probleme bereiten. Ja, warum nicht? Stimmt, warum durften wir das damals eigentlich spielen? Bei Vox? Ich weiß es, keine Ahnung. Die haben noch keine krassen Verträge mit der Gema. Bestimmt kommt da irgendwann noch so eine Rechnung rein. Sind doch Westerland, sind doch 2013 Westerland vor Sarah Connor gesungen, das macht dann 200.000 Euro.
Er kommt so der Kniefall von Scooter so nachher, so zehn Jahre danach und er sagt, es tut mir eigentlich leid. Ja, das kann sehr gut sein. Aber ist ja fast ganz voll, würde ich sagen. Also echt eine Leistung dafür, dass... Also ich habe gestern ein bisschen eingelesen beim Coronavirus und so und da stand dann drin, dass man Grossveranstaltungen meiden soll. Und ich dachte mir so, ja gut, was soll ich jetzt machen? Wollen wir das abblasen? Das ist schwierig, ja. Ich glaube, es wäre auch gut, wenn einer von uns gekommen wäre und der andere nicht. Ja, weil der andere mit so einer Atemschutzmaske. Ja, ja. Ich habe heute tatsächlich in der Innenstadt eine Frau mit Atemmaske gesehen, eine einzige, und ich dachte mir wirklich so, okay, du bist jetzt was Besseres, du darfst überleben und wir alle anderen gehen einfach zugrunde und du darfst dann alleine die Menschheit wieder alleine bevölkern. Dabei sind wir alle nur zu dumm, mal in Rewe zu gehen und so eine Maske zu kaufen, aber das stimmt schon, ich bin auch schon ein bisschen, bitte was? Haben Sie ausverkauft? Ausverkauft? Oh, okay, wir haben die Gesundheitsministerin hier vorne in der ersten Reihe, leider ausverkauft, tut uns leid, aber ja, es ist so schwierig. ist ein Problem. Ja, ich habe gerade auch ein Foto geschickt bekommen von einem Kollegen und der hat auch jetzt eine Maske auf, immer. Das ist jetzt der neue… Crow oder was? Und Crow so, yes! Ich wusste es von Anfang an! Ja, war wie geil, er ist der eine, der sich nicht zum Affen macht, weil er eh schon, also zum Panda macht. Ja, gut, okay, gut. Kennt man Crow heute überhaupt noch? Kommt die Referenz an? Nee, kommt nicht mehr an offensichtlich, unser Publikum ist zu jung für Crow. Oder er ist gestorben mittlerweile, wir wissen es ja nicht, die Lotto-Supp... Man kann ihn einfach auswechseln. Das stimmt. Man kann einfach mit einer neuen Stimme casten und dann nimmst du halt den dann ehligsten Kling. Ist ja eh viel Autotune jetzt auch bei den neuen Crow-Alben, bin ich kein Fan mehr von, ganz im Ernst. So kannst du auch einfach jetzt irgendwen nehmen und den mit dem Panda-Maske aufsetzen, so sieht es nämlich aus, Leute. Ich glaube, eher auch so Daft Punk oder so, die haben sich schon lange zur Ruhe gesetzt und schicken jetzt einfach irgendwie Praktikanten vor mit einer Maske oder so. Ja gut. Vor allem, ich hab mal gehört... Aber gut, dass die Leute Crow nicht verstehen und du kommst mit Daft Punk um die Ecke oder so. Guter Versuch. Ja, die letzte Reihe, die letzte Reihe wiegt schön mit. Ja, so, ja, die kennen wir noch. Ja, die kennen wir noch. Aber es gab mal so irgendeinen iranischen Diktator, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welchen der zwölf Namen der mir einfallen, welcher war es nochmal? 1964, glaube ich. Und der hatte ja, so wenn du Diktator bist, denkst du mir erstmal geil. Hast du es geschafft. Du hast es geschafft, du bist oben, wohin geht es dann noch? Ich glaube, viele haben auch ein Problem, werden dann depressiv so, was ist der nächste Schritt für mich? Aber der Vorteil am Diktator sein, kleiner Tipp am Rande, ist, ihr bekommt Doppelgänger. Ihr bekommt so, wie sagt man, so Dubels, die irgendwo auftauchen, damit die erschossen werden. Stunt Dubels. Damit nicht du erschossen wirst. Und das ist ja das Beste, was du haben kannst, weil du kannst dir vorschicken, es sei denn, und das ist glaube ich einmal tatsächlich passiert, dass einer dieser iranischen Diktatoren einen Arm verloren hat. Was? Und dann willst du nicht sein Double sein.
Ich hab mal so überlegt, ich sehe mich nicht mehr in dieser Branche. Ich sehe mich eigentlich eher so im IT. Oder ich will was mit Menschen machen. Genau, ich habe einen Blog jetzt auch aufgemacht und so, und da kann ich jetzt Vollzeit arbeiten. Ich will mit Menschen machen, weniger mit Diktatoren. Ja, ist schwierig. Oder wenn er so richtig abnimmt, ist auch schwierig. Auch schwierig. Dann ist da so viel Druck drauf. Ja, das ist, aber wenn er zunimmt, geil. Ja, richtig. Jetzt denke ich mir doch, das ist das Beste beim Schauspieler, ich würde ihm immer für eine Rolle zusagen, wo man sehr viel zunehmen muss. Weil niemand im Umfeld kann was sagen, niemand im Umfeld sagt, du hast aber zugelegt. Weil du immer sagen kannst, ich habe diese Rolle, du hast einen Grund, dich schlecht zu ernähren. Sieht man fetter aus oder dünner im Fernsehen? Ich habe es, ich habe's, äh, fett, ah, okay, das ist ein Kompliment oder, ja, ich weiss nie, ob das ein Kompliment ist oder nicht, wenn jemand sagt so, du ist gar nicht so fett wie im Fernsehen. Was man bei dir oft, wir treffen ja euch danach noch, wird heute übrigens auch spannend mit Corona und so, aber wir machen das ja sonst immer nach der Show, wo wir dann, wo dann viele mit euch noch, wir reden dann mit euch noch und unterschreiben Dinge usw. Und viele sagen immer zu dir, oh, du bist aber viel kleiner, als was ich dachte. Und du hast auch danach auch mal zu mir gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob du es ein Kompliment ist oder nicht. Ich sage immer, natürlich nicht, natürlich, willst du doch grösser sein. Ja, es ist schwierig, weil man... Aber im Fernsehen sehen dich ja die meisten Menschen. Heißt, wenn du da grösser wirkst, offensichtlich ist es in der Realität, ist ja eigentlich auch gut. Kommt darauf an, wie gross dein Fernseher ist so ein bisschen. Wenn du halt einfach immer in so einem Kino bist, dann denkt man sich, oh, das ist ja klein, aber die kleinen winzigen Fernseher, da wirkt man eher gross. Neben dir ist es natürlich sehr schwer, gross zu wirken, man wirkt sofort immer klein, das ist ein generelles Problem. Das stimmt, deswegen knie ich mir meistens hin auf Fotos, aber dann sieht man immer im Gesicht, dass man sich hinkniet, weil man immer rot anläuft, weil man kann nicht für eineinhalb Stunden so stehen. Ja, es ist extrem anstrengend zu knien. Ja, ist mir auch aufgefallen. Es ist super anstrengend. In Kirchen, ich gehe einmal im Jahr in die Kirche, Weihnachten, und mittlerweile kniet man nicht mehr. Seit zwei Jahren knie ich nicht mehr. Und das war vorher immer die Hölle. Ich habe das ganze Jahr schon Angst gehabt vor Weihnachten, weil ich wusste, dass irgendwann diese Gabenbereitung und so was, ich bin Katholiker, und dann kniet man sich halt irgendwann hin und da hatte ich immer nie Lust drauf, weil es immer wahnsinnig hart war auf den Knien. Und alle um mich herum waren auch teilweise so neunzigjährige Frauen, die sich einfach hingekniet haben, als wäre es nichts. Die meinen dann auch, man muss ja vor Gott ja auch teilweise Schmerz haben, um ihm das zu beweisen oder keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, woher die Energie kam für sie, offensichtlich von irgendwas extraterrestrischem, aber ich habe diese Energie habe diese Energie nicht. Und deswegen habe ich immer Tränen geäunt. Ich dachte immer, wem betet er gerade, an wen denkt er gerade, ich wollte einfach nur aufstehen. Es ist auch ein bisschen ein Zeichen für die Dummheit des Menschen, du hast Gott, der erschafft den Menschen und gibt ihm Füsse und Beine und eine Wirbelsäule, die alles perfekt funktionieren zusammen. Und er kniet sich hin und Gott so, nee, nee, du machst das völlig falsch. Mach mal Liegestütz jetzt. Wie so ein Kind, dem man so ein Handy schickt und es steckt sich so die Nase einfach sofort und man so, nee, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ja und Gott ist auch so, wir machen mal zehn Liegestütz jetzt, wir machen jetzt 20 Sit-ups. Du Fetti. Ja, das frage ich mich auch, warum dann knien so, wir hätten uns auch alle auf zehn Liegestütz eingehen können. Aber tatsächlich ein sehr, sehr schön, vielleicht das schönste Foto von mir 2019 war an Heiligabend und es ist glaube ich so, wenn du Kinder hast, dann nimmst du Weihnachten immer noch extrem ernst und jetzt kommt der Weihnachtsmann und dann Geschenke und so. Und dann nimmt es aber so ab, wenn die Kinder immer älter werden. Und man merkt so, okay, die Eltern stecken immer weniger Wert auf Weihnachten, was ja auch völlig legitim ist. Immer weniger Kugeln hängen am Baum. Weniger Kugeln und dieses Jahr war der Baum wirklich sehr klein, muss man wirklich sagen.
Klein. Also ich glaube, es ist das letzte Jahr mit Baum, nächstes Jahr ist dann kein Baum. Aber es gibt dieses eine traurige Jahr vor kein Baum und dann war dieser wirklich winzige Baum, der auf dem Tisch stand, was schon mal ein schlechtes Zeichen. Ja, ja, was immer, wir wollen es kaschieren.
Genau, und dann heißt es so, und meine Mutter so, ja, ähm, ach, kniet euch da mal lieber hin, dann sieht der Baum grösser aus.
Und meine Brüder und ich knien vor diesem Baum, meine Mutter macht natürlich ein Foto mit dem Boden und uns knien drinnen drauf. Und wir haben jetzt für immer ein Weihnachtsfoto von 2019, wo wir alle zu dritt knien versuchen, möglichst nicht so auszusehen, als ob wir knien würden. Geben Thumbs up und jeder Mensch, bei Verstand, der das sieht, denkt sich, in welcher Sekte seid ihr eigentlich gelandet? Und dann auch so, kattest du irgendein random Typ und dann sagt so, ja, Familie Will wünscht frohe Weihnachten, Freaks. Ja genau, Familie Will wurde entführt und wünscht frohe Weihnachten. Ja, das ist einfach so. Was ist mit Familie Will passiert eigentlich? Jedes Jahr wird der Baum kleiner? Ja. Weird. Nee, aber knien auch... Aber gut, dass wir gerade mitten in Topical Island sind, ob sie Weihnachten, das ist unser Thema heute. Ja, für unsere afrikanischen Zuhörer, wir haben ja letztes Mal gehört, dass in Kenia gerade Weihnachten ist, von daher kann man sie da zeigen. Hat das mal irgendwer verstanden? Ihr googelt immer allen Kack und dann kriegt man so viele Mails, aber hat jemand verstanden, warum in Kenia gerade Weihnachten ist? Niemand versteht es. Dreh sich die Erde jetzt andersrum oder was? Oder vertikal? Aber zum Thema Knie, ich bin auch... Heutzutage, ja. Ich bin auch kein Fan von Schuhebinden, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Schuhebinden, auch dieses so, dieses auf die Knie gehen, ist für mich sehr unangenehm. Ich mag das nicht. Ist nicht meine Bewegung. Das ist immer die Frage, wenn man auf der Strasse steht, ob man dann den macht oder nicht. Meine Knie knacken auch immer ganz doll. Hör mal das? Oh! Oh Gott! Das kann doch nicht gesund sein. Du bist vor allem der von uns, der Sport macht. Ja, aber ich dachte, es wird auch besser dadurch oder sowas. Das wäre mein Hauptgrund, warum ich angefangen habe mit Sport. Nein, das ist das Signal des Körpers, das sagt, hör auf, lass es, keine Schuhe, wir lassen Schuhe. Niemand aus der ganzen Welt hat das, glaube ich. Ja? Weiß nicht. Aber ich habe, weil es haben sehr wenige, auch wenn alle hier so reagieren, ist ja, das ist ja gerade, das ist eigentlich das beste Net-Doktor, was man haben kann. Weil bei Net-Doktor sieht man immer so grob, ob das schlimm ist oder nicht, wenn es viele haben und so und dann viele kriegt man auch, werden beruhigt. Aber wenn hier der ganze Saal reagiert, woho, dann weiss man, ist das immer arg. Aber ich weiß immer, wenn ich mich hinknie, das erste Mal in einer Stunde, also danach wird es dann wieder aufgeladen, die Batterie, die Knackbatterie, so und nach einer Stunde kann ich mich wieder hinknie und dann knackt es wieder. Machen wir gleich mal, testen wir. Wir können auf drei knien sich bitte alle hin und wir können einfach genau den Mittelwert an Geräusch feststellen, das man sollte.
Das finde ich mal spannend.
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen schwer umzusetzen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, das hat, wie gesagt, das hat in der katholischen Kirche nicht funktioniert, also wird es hier auch nicht funktionieren, glaube ich. Doch, okay. Okay, da ist jemand dabei. Alles klar, gut, Wiederwahl steht noch aus. Aber was ich mir so so, hast du dir vorgenommen, vorher die ganze Zeit reinzurufen oder ist die Idee gerade entstanden? Oder ist das erst bei der Weinschorle entstanden, die Idee? Das frage ich mich die ganze Zeit. Ohne Scheisse, wenn ich, wenn ich, ich denke mir immer, bei jeder Comedyveranstaltung, heute mal häkeln, machst du natürlich nie. Nein, aber natürlich hast du dir Gedanken. Genau wie ich kaum Klassikkonzerte besuchen kann, ohne die ganze Zeit zu denken, oh, bitte hab jetzt keinen spassischen Anfall und schrei los. Weil die ganze Zeit denke ich mir, es ist gerade so ruhig, es ist gerade so ruhig, hoffentlich geht mein Handy nicht, ich habe immer das irgendwie dieses, was viele Leute haben, so habe ich mein Herz zuhause angelassen, so geht es mir mit meinem Handy die ganze Zeit, bei den Klassikkonzerten und ich kann mich nie konzentrieren oder nie den Moment genießen, weil ich immer denke, wann geht es los, es ruft man gleich an. Ja und dann Beethoven, dritter Satz und du spürst dieses Gefühl in deinem Knie und du weisst, gleich geht es los und du sagst, Knie, halt die Fresse, Knie, jetzt nicht, ich brauch dich jetzt, ich war immer gut zu dir, sei jetzt gut zu mir, hör auf! Und alle drehen sich so um. Wie oft musst du während einer Veranstaltung husten, bevor du gehst? Bitte? Ich habe, glaube ich, schon mal, ich glaube, ich habe, ich glaube, ich habe, glaube ich mal achtmal, ich habe, ich sass mal irgendwo im Publikum, glaube ich, im Theater und ich habe acht Mal hintereinander gehustet und gesagt, okay, das war's, ich gehe. Jetzt kannst du gehen. Ach so. Und denkst du einfach, wie lange geht das jetzt so weiter? Okay, die Seite ist Corona vergiftet, die nicht. Und dann gehe ich, nach acht Mal gehe ich. Das war meine Zahl. Warum ist es so ein bisschen, bis das Publikum so ein Epizentrum ausgemacht hat mit den Köpfen. Ja genau.
Man sieht ja bei Klassikkonzerten oft sehr viele graue Häupter.
Es ist wie so ein Magnetfeld, wo sich alle dann so hinbewegen.
Ja genau, und man sieht so sehr viele graue Häupter, beim zweiten Mal Husten kommt schon der erste German Stare, und dann werden es mehr.
Mit jedem Huster proportional mehr Menschen, so potenzmässig, und irgendwann nach Huster vier, glaube ich, auch der Dirigent dann irgendwann so. Was ist los? Und dann, glaube ich, kannst du gehen. Ruckartiges Hinschauen ist generell meine einzige Waffe. Ich bin letztens wieder auf dem Zug gefahren, neben einem schreienden Kind. Und das ist immer so, du musst ja überlegen... Aber Babys kannst du nicht... Ja, genau, wen schaust du... Babys gucken durch dich durch. Babys gucken, das ist mein großes Ziel, mein Blickduell gegen Baby zu gewinnen. Ja, vergiss es. Und gegen Hunde verliere ich ja schon. Ey, Hund gegen Baby, das würde ich mir anschauen. Das würde ich mir anschauen. So, und das ist unsere neue Show auf Vox. Auf Vox, wer schaut zuerst weg? Keine Chance. Wobei viele Duelle Hund gegen Baby gehen eher zu Lasten des Babys, würde ich mal sagen. Rein kräftemässig. Ja, kommt drauf an. Das Problem ist ja, wenn du, Eltern sind ja oft auch nicht auf der Seite ihres Kindes. Ganz im Gegenteil. Die sind ja genauso feindlich dem Kind gegenüber. So hatte ich es genau mit der Mutter, weil du hast dann dieses schreiende Kind. Nochmal, deine Kindheit tut mir wahnsinnig leid. Pass auf. Nee, aber ich hatte genau die Erfahrung, schreiendes Kind und Mutter. Und dann denkst du dir, okay, 40 Prozent meiner bösen Blicke gehen aufs Kind, aber ich habe auch noch 60 Prozent meiner bösen Blicke für die Mutter übrig. Hund? Aufs Kind. Aber ist Hund auch in dem Szenario oder gar nicht im Szenario? Kein Hund, vergiss den Hund. Ja, ja, vergiss den Hund. Weil du gerade von einem Hund gesprochen hast, deswegen dachte ich, dass er noch eine ist. Nein, nein, nein, das Kind schreit, ich schaue die Mutter an, die Mutter erwidert meinen Blick und gibt mir so ein Ja... und ich so, nee, nicht, ja, sondern nee, ich bin schuld, die die mutter hat sich damit mir verbündet gegen das baby wir haben beide das baby böse angeschaut dem baby war das scheißegal weiter geschrieben und du hast keine chance oder schreit das baby die hunde oder ei situation schreit das baby weil die mutter sich gegen das kind wendet ja ja schwierig schwierig da gehenail gehen. Aber kriegt der Hund von dir böse Blicke, wenn da noch ein Hund wäre in dem Szenario?
Ja, ich glaube schon auch. Ich glaube, Hunde haben auch schon so ein, okay, jetzt habe ich es übertrieben, jetzt ist was zu viel.
Da kommt der Blick weg.
Ja, der Blick weg. Was ich aber jetzt neu entwickelt habe und was nicht funktioniert, also versucht es erst gar nicht, ist, weil ich reise immer im Ruheabteil, ist der, also das Problem ist, junge Männer entwickeln eine Fähigkeit zum Gähnen, wann immer sie gähnen müssen, um nur den klassischen Gähner zu machen. Also das Gähnen ist eine sehr vielseitige Geste, man kann es immer gut einsetzen, um in Umarmungen zu kommen, aus Umarmungen rauszukommen, es ist immer perfekt, aber je älter man wird, desto weniger kann man es einsetzen. Du bist der Erste, der sich darüber Gedanken gemacht, aus einer Umarmung rauszukommen. Als ob... das ist manchmal gar nicht so leicht. Das stimmt schon auch. Weg. Einfach mit so einem Ratschlag. Einfach weg. Und weg. Nie mehr, da habe ich nie mehr gesehen. Ja, seitdem waren wir getrennt. Ich weiß nicht, was danach passiert ist. Aber was ich jetzt mittlerweile versucht habe, wenn ich im Ruheabteil sitze, gibt es ja immer oben auf der Höhe dieses Zeichen Ruheabteil. Immer wenn ich den Blick fange von jemandem, der laut ist, mache ich den Gähner und tippse auf das Wurzeln. Nein! Oh mein Gott! Das ist grauenhaft. Nein! Was soll ich tun? Was soll ich tun? Erfolgsquote zero. Nichts. Null, null, noch nie verstanden, noch nie angekommen, noch nie was gebracht. Aber ich kriege auch ganz oft böse Blicke und dann, das ist ganz lustig eigentlich, weil ich habe, wenn man manchmal einen Rollkoffer dabei hat und man fährt jemanden so aus Versehen in die Hacken, dann kriegt man immer so einen ganz bösen Blick. Was, wirklich? Einen ganz bösen Blick? Die gucken dich böse an, wenn du ihn in die Hand fährst. So leicht, ich rede jetzt nicht von einem aggressiven, sondern so einem leichten Anschubser, nicht dieser Stewardess macht den Weg frei, sondern so ein leicht, oh, und dann gucken die sich immer böse um und behalten dann den Blick und dann sagt man, oh, tut mir sehr leid, und dann sagen die, ja, ist doch gar kein Problem. Und ich denke mir jedes Mal, und das Lieben, ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen so ein
deutsches Bahnding, so man liebt, dann kurz jemanden in der Macht zu haben und zu sagen,
ja, ist doch gar kein Problem. Wir sind doch ja alle Freunde, oder? Und man hat kurz jemanden in der Macht und ich verstehe gar nicht, warum man überhaupt auf die Idee kommt, um das so böse zu gucken, wenn dann alles okay war. Habe ich neulich mal gefragt. Wenn dann alles so grossig ist, warum gucken Sie mich dann so böse an? Daraufhin noch ein böserer Blick. Ja, ja, aber das ist auch die brutalste Gewalt, die man ausüben kann, ist, wenn man Menschen tatsächlich ihre Wünsche erfüllt. So dieses, ach komm, ich helfe dir schnell, das zu tragen, nee, brauchst du nicht, ja, gut, doch nicht. So, die Person würde auf der Stelle tot umfallen, weil das immer so, ach nee, komm, zahl dich selber, brauchst du nicht und so, aber damit wird immer impliziert, man will es doch, wenn man einfach sagen wird, ja, gut, doch nicht, dann schau. Ja, ich ziehe ja auch morgen um und das sind immer so, ach nee, komm, zahl dich selber, brauchst du nicht und so, aber damit impliziert, immer impliziert, man will's doch, wenn man einfach sagen wird, oh gut, noch nicht, dann schau. Ja, ich ziehe auch morgen um und das sind immer so die Dinge, wo man merkt, ah okay, so gute Freunde hat man jetzt, sind die und ich trau mich zum einen niemals, ja. Scheiße, ich hab leider, mir fällt gerade ein, ich hab dir vor Monaten das Save-to-Date geschickt, so und jetzt, ja, scheiße, ich hab morgen Termin, fuck. Und dann gibt's ja noch welche, die dann kommen und dann immer bei jedem Möbelspieler so sagen, ja, warte, ich helfe, ja, warte, ich helfe. Und dann ist man schon meilenbein weg. Ja, das ist ein Zombiegang machen, in der Hoffnung, dass in der Zwischenzeit, ja, das ist ein Pseudo, dieses Pseudo, ja, komm, ich helfe, ich helfe. Und dann trinkt man noch was und dann stellt man uns dann noch weg und wartet so, bis diese Kolonne weggezogen ist. Ja. Kennt man das, PHelfen. Oh, die Top-5 Möglichkeiten, bei einem Umzug Zeit zu sparen auf Platz… Die Top-10. Ja, okay, machen wir Top-20 draus, fuck it, re-race. Auf Platz Nummer 20, immer bevor und nachdem man etwas abstellt, gute sieben Sekunden nichts tun. Erstmal, du hast diese Kiste vor dir und dann erstmal so evaluieren, so zwei Griffe, eine Kiste. Okay, okay, okay, okay. Ich habe zwei Hände, eine links, eine rechts, klar, okay, wie machen wir das jetzt hier? Linker Hand, linker Griff, rechter Hand, rechter Griff und los geht's. Und dann Treppe hoch und dann erst mal abstellen und dann so alles gleich, hier steht die Kiste jetzt, okay, wunderbar. Rechteck, okay, Volumen, wunderbar. Dann so an die Wand tippen, damit Flur genug Platz ist. Steht die okay hier? Steht die? Nee, wir räumen erst mal alles hoch. Okay, steht die? Okay, Volumen, wunderbar. Also an die Wand tippen, damit Flur und Flur genug Platz ist. Steht die okay hier? Steht die? Nee, wir räumen erstmal alles hoch. Okay, steht die? Okay. Nee, dann ist die ja. Und dann wieder runter geht. Das liest du Shades of Grey? Ja, aber das läppert sich, wirklich. Wenn du zehn Gänge hast und jedes Mal sieben Sekunden Pause hast. Ja, Platz 19 in der neuen Wohnung erstmal neue. Hast du gerade gemerkt, wie ich nicht ausrechnen konnte und deswegen zur alten Mathe-LK-Technik das gegriffen habe?
Boah, Sinus von 90 Grad. Wow, das ist ganz schön viel. Okay, tschau Leute, macht's gut, ich muss nicht ausreden, sorry.
Nee, erst mal in der neuen Wohnung dann anfangen, Mängel zu finden, um nicht mehr zur alten Wohnung zu müssen und neue Sachen zu bringen, erst mal so, oh, muss auch neu verputzt werden. Und erst mal in der neuen Wohnung dann so anfangen, Dinge zu finden, um dann da halt mit Platz, Zeit zu verschwenden und dann da in der neuen Wohnung erstmal zu gucken und dann da Zeit zu verbringen. Das ist auch, beim Umzug kannst du, glaube ich, viel, viel Scheiss auch machen, einfach viel, viel nicht helfen. Ja, Platz Nummer 19, der sein, der immer fragt, ob noch mehr du was zu trinken willst. Ja. Will noch mehr was zu trinken? Ja. Ne, also du willst noch eine Flasche, okay, ich hole dir eine Flasche Wasser. Ja, ja. Aus dem Keller, Edeka, anderes Land, Frankreich. Mit der Pizzabestellung viel Zeit verschwenden auch so. Ja, genau. Ne, es ging jetzt nicht mehr, ne, der hat gerade, der doch zuschaut, wir müssen noch bei Piccolini nicht sein. Ja, komisch, äh, wie, jetzt habe ich schon vergessen, wie das jetzt heißt. Deliveroo hat jetzt zugemacht. Komisch, brauchen wir jetzt ... Okay, welche Apps gibt's? Ich recherchiere mal. Ich recherchiere und überlege mal. Ich recherchiere mal weiter. Frag dir mal erst mal den Flügel rein. Ja. Wobei ich immer versuche, der zu sein, der die ersten zehn Minuten richtig Gas gibt, so dass sich alle anderen schlecht fühlen, und wenn alle anderen sich schlecht fühlen und versuchen, ihr Pensum aufzuholen, dann lege ich mich hin.
Dein Instagram.
So, weil dann, weil Leute sind dumm, wenn die mal eine Überzeugung im Kopf haben,
wird die nicht mehr kontrolliert, wenn die denkt, oh, der ist fleissig, kann die danach
irgendwie liegend sehen, denkt sich, ja klar, der liegt, weil er so fleissig war, muss er sich
ausruhen und die daten ihre Überzeugung nicht ab und deswegen erst guter Eindruck machen,
dann schlafen, perfekt.
Platz 16, schon am Vorabend ankündigen, dass man irgendwie fiebert. Um dann halt irgendwie nach dem ersten Bett zu sagen, ja nee, sorry, ich glaube, ich schwächel. Ich schwächel. Ich habe gerade diese Reportage über Corona gesehen und jetzt geht es mir irgendwie so ganz dreckig, irgendwie ganz komisch geht es mir jetzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schaffe. Ist vielleicht auch besser, wenn ich zuhause bleibe. Ja, ich hab so einen Kratzen im Hals. Aber ich bin echt erstaunt, dass doch so viele, ich lass mal diese Rubrik so ein bisschen auslaufen. Wir können darauf zurückkommen, wenn wir noch 15 ... Ja, wenn uns 15 andere Sachen einfällt. Ja, aber ich find's dann doch beeindruckend, dass so viele hier sind. Ich bin gespannt, wie wir es gleich hinkriegen, wenn am Ende, wenn wir dann nochmal alle Fotos machen und so. Bin ich sehr gespannt.
Ich meine, das Coolste an diesem Coronavirus finde ich ja immer dieses detektivische Zurückrecherchieren, wo es herkommt. So dieses, wo ist es zuerst ausgebrochen? Waren es die Fledermäuse jetzt? Genau, und am Ende, und dann suchst du, okay, die hatten es zuerst und dann der und dann der und am Ende hast du ein armes Schwein, das halt dann vor der Kamera steht und sagt, Und dieser eine Mann hat mit einer toten Fledermaus Sex gehabt und hat dadurch den Corona-Virus und der Typ einfach so, ja, ja. Ich meine, wir alle haben sexuell schon Dinge gemacht, für die wir uns schämen. Der arme Mann. Und wer dann auch in die Kamera, in die weltweite Presse kommt, als du bist schuld, dass du es ausgelöst hast. Und so eine Leine hinterher sich herstet mit so einer toten Fledermann. Ja, genau. Oder die fliegt noch. Aber warum hat man nicht Flughunde domestiziert, sondern richtige Hunde? Statt Flughäie, wie man es sonst gemacht hat oder was. Nee, weil Flughunde hätte man ja auch domestizieren können. Und dann bellen die so und dann hast du aber die an der Leine und dann fliegen die aber so rum. Und dann kannst du durch die Fußball-Anzeite... Was ist dieses Hundethema bei dir, Stefan? Kommt da ein Hund oder was? Klopft da jemand an? Ja? Was? Oh, den kann ich mir gerade gar nicht vorstellen. Ich kann mir Stefan mit Hund überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Ich bin auch sofort nicht mehr Alpha im Haus. Genau. Ich bin sofort Beta-Männchen. Ja, Platz Nummer zwei. Angeknurrt. Wenn ich wieder einen Fisch hätte, drei. Aber ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht mit dem Hund. Aber mit einem Flughund wäre doch geil. Warum kann man, warum heißt es Flughund? Haben es irgendwas mit Hunden zu tun? Nein. Keine Ahnung, Biologen sind … Man hat immer genug Wörter gehabt und dann sagt man … Es gibt Tiere, die heißen Nasenbär. Wenn es eine unkreativere Menschengruppe als Biologen gibt, gibt's nicht. Dann Deutsche. So, das ist einfach Nasenbär, Grönland, Braunbär, so. Ja, Weisbär, Eisbär, Weisbär, Eisbär. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, aber hast du nicht so ein bisschen auch das Gefühl, wenn … Dass wir mehr Angst haben müssen. Ja, ne, dass wir weniger Angst haben müssen, weil wenn du jetzt den Coronavirus kriegst, schnüsst du morgen mit derZeitung. Ja. Stefan Tietze, at Esteban Tizioso von der Podcast UFO, Podcast Doppelpunkt das UFO. Der Podcast UFO, Band, POFO. Genau, ja. Gestern im Hotel. Der aus dem Alien-Podcast. Ich glaube, du stimmst morgen ohne Scheiss Schlagzeits. Das stimmt wirklich, ne? Angenommen, wir würden uns heute Abend mit Corona Corona und deswegen machen wir diese ganze Autogrammscheiss. Aber deswegen müssen wir es unbedingt machen, weil auf jeden Fall muss auch derjenige von euch, der Corona hat, der so ein leichtes Kribbeln hat, muss auf jeden Fall zu uns kommen. Ja, hustet uns an, jeder einmal anhusten. Ja, genau. Wie so alte Männer in der Kirche, bei denen der Pfarrer die Oplade noch auf die Zunge gelegt hat. Ach so. Und jeder darf einmal in uns rein niesen. Wir machen Mund auf und jeder hustet einmal rein, wir machen eine lange Reihe einfach, jeder darf einmal rein husten. Dann haben wir es ja und noch ein paar Untheb-Hepartesis-D und so, bis er ja. Und dann fangen wir an, Leuten das zu sagen und dann sind wir der erste Prominentenfall. Ja, weil ich glaube, die Bild-Zeitung ruft mittlerweile jeden Tag bei Jürgen von der Lippe an oder bei irgendjemandem und sagt, ist es schon so weit, haben wir Corona, ist es Olli Pocher, haben wir Corona, ist es irgendwas? Haben Sie es? Haben Sie es schon? Nein. Ja, ich fühle mich ein bisschen schwummrig, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Der Papst, der Papst hat ja so ein leichtes Kratzen im Hals und da haben viele gesagt, oh, aber auch ein komisches Zeichen, wenn ausgerechnet der Papst jetzt kann. Das wäre ein sehr schlechtes Zeichen, ja, wenn der Papst der erste Prominente wäre. Das würden die doch locker vertuschen, erstmal ist die Teilnehmer eh gerade gefährdet, aber das würden die doch locker irgendwie hinterm Berg halten, weil das ist doch ein Trauerspiel, wenn jetzt der Papst of all people, der gottgewählte Mann jetzt stirbt an Corona. Aber kommt dann kommt dann Ratzinger zurück eigentlich? Oh! Ist er nochmal, wie so Robin, der dann den Batman-Posten übernimmt oder so? Holy shit, das ist gar nicht so doof. Weiß ich gar nicht. Ja, weird. Aber ich weiß nicht, aber vor allem, kann man nicht einfach behaupten, dass man Corona hätte, um in die Zeitung zu kommen oder so? Ja, dann kommen die ja die Bild-Zeitung mit so einem Abstrich. Wirklich? Aber man kann ja so bei Verwandten so, Schlagzeile, meine Oma hat Corona. So einfach und dann kannst du es einfach niemanden kann zu überprüfen. Das reint sich auch geil. Ja, das ist natürlich. Meine Oma hat Corona. Wie heisst sie? Corinna. Ja, es ist jetzt ungezigt für ihre Zeitung Meine Oma aus Paloma hat Corona. Ist leider ein so. Oma Corinna aus Paloma hat Corona. Und die Bild so. Wow! Das wäre die Schlagzeile, das wäre die Schlagzeile. Na mal gucken, was heute Abend passiert, wir schauen mal. Ich bin offen, aber ich habe keine Angst, ich habe keine Angst und ich sage dir warum, weil die meisten Artikel noch hinter der Paywall sind. Das stimmt, ja. Und ohne Scheiß, ich habe keine Angst vor Dingen, die hinter Paywall-Artikeln versteckt sind. Ohne Witz, wenn morgen mein Sexvideo leaken würde, ich hätte keine Angst, weil es wäre hinter der Paywall. Wahrscheinlich. Bei dir glaube ich nicht. Meinst du, bitte was? Das nehme ich jetzt als persönlich. Du würdest kein Geld für mein Sexvideo zahlen? Du würdest kein Geld für mein Sexvideo zahlen? Ja doch, aber... Also, 1,990 bin ich dir nicht wert, oder was? Ist auch sehr kurz, da kann man durchskippen. Ich wäre der Erste, der das in die Pufo-Telegram-Gruppe posten würde. Schön auf die Pufopedia hochladen, für alle. Nee, aber das, ja, nee, ich glaube so, wo waren wir gerade stehen geblieben? Vor allem, ja, aber ich glaube, wenn du diese redaktionelle Rückarbeitung auf diesen einen armen Menschen, den mit der Federmaus Sex hatte, ich glaube, genauso wird diese Rückarbeitung auf den heutigen Abend fallen. Weil man in hundert Jahren wissen will, wie konnte es sein, weil hier irgendjemand Corona hat und hier alles verstreut wird. Wobei der Fresh, genau. Eigentlich gab es ja genug Bottlenecks so, aber wir haben es einfach ... und flieg, jetzt verbreitet dich Corona. Wir waren der schuldige Abend. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich meine ... Nach Karneval ist doch eh alles gelaufen jetzt. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber vor allem, Corona ist ja schon so ein bisschen, ich sag nicht cool, aber ich sag angesagt gerade. Was jetzt richtig ärgerlich wäre, was jetzt richtig ärgerlich wäre, wenn man jetzt zum Arzt geht und dann sagt, ja, tut mir leid, ich muss Ihnen sagen, Sie haben leider die Vogelgrippe. Und ich so, was, eine Krankheit aus 2013, willst du mich verarschen? Kann ich ja nicht mal Corona haben? Fuck, Alter, das interessiert niemanden. Das ist so eine schlimme Krankheit einfach jetzt. So eine sehr schlimme Krankheit, die in allen normalen Zeiten schlimm wäre. Aber jetzt bist du so egal. Mein Leben an hat jemand einen leichten Schnupfen. Aber das würde passen. Ich habe Folgrippe und du Maul und Klauen solche einfach. Und wir haben immer so, wo ist unsere Schlagzeile? Und wir sterben wirklich fast, kommen aber nicht mehr in Quarantäne. Ist nicht jetzt der beste Zeitpunkt für andere Krankheiten? Ohne Scheiss. Ich wär so gerne in Quarantäne, ohne Witz. Ja! Ey, das einzige, so gerne, wenn die sagen, okay, wir isolieren sie jetzt von allen anderen Menschen. Ich so, okay, kommt zum Nachteil, kommt, wo ist das Problem? Sie müssen sich für, sie können sich alles mitnehmen, Switch, Nintendo Switch, so alles gut, alles mitnehmen, ihre Lieblingskuscheldecke, aber Sie müssen sich von allen anderen Menschen auf ungewisse Zeit erstmal fernhalten. Okay, was muss ich dafür machen? Sie kommen einfach zu uns im Krankenhaus morgen und heute Abend keinen mehr treffen, unbedingt, und dann kommen Sie morgen einfach ins Auto, umso mit einer Magenschutzmaske, berühren Sie niemanden und kommen Sie dann einfach zu uns, melden sich an, die wissen schon Bescheid, sie kriegen ja halt diese Krankenhaushalpflegung ganz normal und so.
Ja, cool, ich komme dann einfach in meinem riesigen Plastikball angerollt, den ich mir eh schon für private Zwecke gekauft habe, der hat einfach richtig gut kommt. Ich glaube wirklich, diese eine Frau mit dem Mundschutz, den ich heute gesehen habe, morgen kommt die in so einem Plastikball, in die U-Bahn gerollt. Ja genau, weil wir haben heute darüber gesprochen, es ist ja spannend irgendwie, weil in, in, ähm, ich habe heute auch eine Asiatin in der Bahn gesehen mit einer, mit einem Mundschutz. Und mein rassistisches Inneres sagt gesagt, oh, jetzt fühlst du dich ja vielleicht ein bisschen wie zuhause. Oh Gott! Nein, nur, nein, nein, ja, Buh geschenkt, auf jeden Fall, Buh. Aber, ähm, das habe ich ja auch gesagt zu meinem Gehirn, Bn, bu. Dein Gehirn hat es gesagt, nicht du. Man muss es wirklich unterscheiden. Man kann schlecht trennen. Aber ich habe gedacht, man kennt ja viele Videos aus der Tokio-U-Bahn, wo einfach alle dann Mundschutz tragen und so, um Leute um sich herum davon zu bewahren. Genau, aber ist es nicht so, dass man da den Mundschutz trägt, wenn man selber krank ist, um die anderen zu schützen? Weiß ich nicht genau, ich kann mich mir vorstellen. Aber in Deutschland trägt man es ja gerade, weil man Angst hat, weil man sich von Menschen fernhalten, weil man die Gefahr hinter jeder Ecke lauern sieht. Eigentlich wäre es doch klüger, wenn man den Leuten, die Corona haben, den Mundschutz geben. Die sind eigentlich Quarantäne. Na gut. Haben wir es doch gelöst. Haben wir es doch gelöst. Freunde, ist auch perfekt, ist auch wunderbar.
Ich habe aber, ich habe tatsächlich jemandem die Hand geschüttelt, der auf diesem, also wir machen gerade so Nachvertonungsarbeiten für die Serie, und dann kam ein Schauspieler, der hieß es erst, der kann vielleicht nicht kommen, weil der gerade in Thailand auf so einem Kreuzfahrtschiff festrennt, weil er nämlich Animateur ist. Er ist Animateur, das sind die Leute, die alle anfassen am Schiff, weil die immer mit dem Volleyball spielen wollen oder so Wasserball, Gymnastik mässiges Zeug machen wollen. Und der hing auf so einem solchen Schiff fest, lag dann irgendwie zwei Wochen vor Thailand und dann kam er doch zurück und hat mir direkt beim Reinkommen die Hand gegeben und ich habe sie genommen und mich gefreut und habe kurz vergessen, was seine Backstory war.
Und das heißt, vielleicht habe ich es auch. Okay. Nur so als kleiner Disclaimer. Okay, okay. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber ist es ein gutes Zeichen, wenn du auf einem Kreuzfahrtschiff festhängst, eigentlich sowas, jeden Tag Buffet essen, oh Gott. Aber das Dumme ist ja, die haben ja Unterhaltung, die haben ja jeden Tag ein anderes Unterhaltungsprogramm und wenn die feststecken irgendwo, dann haben die ein echtes Problem, weil dann das Mädchen mit der Tuba nochmal auftreten muss und er so, wir haben doch die Tuba schon gesehen und ein riesiger Aufstand. Wovor haben die wahrscheinlich sieben Musicals eingeprobt, so für jeden Abend, in die Cats, Starlight Express und so müssen sich immer nochmal Cats aufhören und das Publikum ist auch genervt irgendwann mittlerweile.
Und irgendwann gehen auch die Nahrungsvorräte zu neigen und sowas. Ja, ja, ja. Das ist ein grosses Problem. Ist ein riesiges, ist ein riesiges, unsere, unsere, unsere, unsere Gebete gehen raus an alle, die momentan auf Kreuzfahrtschiffen festhängen und vielleicht diesen Podcast hören und die denken, Dankeschön, danke, dass jemand an mich denkt, vielen, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank. Shoutout auch an alle, die Maul und Klau und solche haben, oder geht auch mal! Die darf man nicht vergessen, es gibt keine Modekrankheiten, nee, nee, nee, es gibt keine Modekrankheiten, jeder, alle Krankheiten sind gleich. Ja. Ja. Hast du mal irgendwo festgesteckt wegen irgend sowas? Hab ich mal irgendwo festgesteckt? Ich hab als Kind mal versucht, durch die Katzenklappe zu kommen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema, aber bin ich mal irgendwo fest… Und seitdem gibt es Unternehmen, die Florentin-Klappe. Ja. Die ist für dich. Die kannst du so nehmen. Mit ganz viel Vaseline außenrum. Sehr viel Vaseline und im Prinzip eine Tür. Man wusste immer so, ah, Florentin ist wieder zu Hause. Das ganze Haus wusste Bescheid einfach. Man wusste immer auch wie so ein Neugeborenen, weil er so Vaseline war. Hallo? Ich bin einmal, glaube ich, irgendwo festgesteckt, weil ich zu dumm war, rechtzeitig aus dem Zug auszusteigen und bin irgendwie zwei, in einem ICE, zwei Stationen zu weit gefahren. Dann kannst du auch, das kannst du einfach einpacken. Und es war der letzte Zug. Du bist am Archibelt. Und dann habe ich aber tatsächlich in der Car2Go-Map, die hat ja irgendwie in den grossen Städten immer so Autos, und dann war aber so eine ganz kleine Insel ausserhalb von dem Bereich. Und das war genau da, wo ich war. Das war in der Nähe von Bonn und da gibt es eine ganz kleine Insel, wo zwei Autos drin waren und das war genial. Da war wirklich so der Car2Go-Gott hat mich gerettet. Wahrscheinlich war es häufiger passiert. Kann schon sein. Und aus meiner, wo ich vielleicht ein unterhaltsames Chlor-Lektüre-Buch draus mache, witzige Dinge, die ich in Car-to-Go-Autos gefunden habe, bis jetzt auf Platz Nummer drei eine Avocado, auf Platz Nummer zwei eine Bibel tatsächlich. Also da ist tatsächlich irgendjemand während der Car-to-Go-Fahrt vom Glauben abgefallen und hat gesagt, brauche ich nicht mehr. Aber ich verstehe es. Satan, nimm meine Seele! Wie geht der Scheibenbüscher von hinten aus? Das ist Satans Wern. Aber jetzt auf Platz eins steige ich in so ein Car2Go-Auto in Smart, sehr klein, und da sind drin zwei grosse Metallstangen, die komplett durchs ganze Auto gehen. Und ich denke, niemand kann das vergessen. Du sitzt nicht mit zwei Metallstangen, die dir so direkt an die Schläfe drücken und steigst aus und denkst so, vergessen irgendwie, es geht nicht. Also es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Alternativen, entweder ist jemand so extrem vergesslich, dass er das vergisst, oder jemand benutzt Car2Go Autos als Sperrmüllablage und sagt einfach so, ich habe eine alte Waschmaschine, ja kein Problem, gar nicht so blöd, wenn du da zum Wertstoffhof gehst und 12 Euro zahlst, ha, hau die in ein Car-to-Go-Auto und Park irgendwo. Full in Smart. Fuck it, interessiert niemanden. Aber man konnte ja vorher bei DriveNow und so, konnte man ja eingeben, wie sauber dein Fahrer. Ja, genau. Wo ich mich immer gefragt habe, aber wie gemein, weil der muss es ja auch nicht dringelassen haben. Der kann es ja auch erst vorgefunden haben, deswegen dachte ich mir immer, räume ich jetzt, ich habe dann oft auch einfach Car-to-Gos tagelang ausgesaugt und ausgeräumt, weil ich ja keine schlechte Bewertung haben will. Aber ich habe diese Stangen ja nicht da drin gelassen. Genau, deswegen habe ich dieses auch das erste Mal Feedback gegeben zum Auto, damit nicht der, der danach sagen kann, Florentin Wille hat hier Stangen drin gelassen. Und da habe ich geschrieben, wie hat in die Fahrt gefallen, zwei von fünf Sterne mit Kommentar, zwei lange Metallstangen, lol. lol ich glaube ich noch nie glaub ich, noch nie lol geschrieben, aber da musste ich einfach, da wollte ich einfach ablollen, einfach, ich war in lol-Laune. Du hast lol geschrieben. Und dann hab ich überlegt, soll ich lange Stangen schreiben, weil eine Stange ist immer lang eigentlich. Wenn's kurz, es gibt keine kurzen Stangen. Stab. Ja, ein Stock ist, aber dann ist es ein Stock. Stab ist eine kurze Stange. Ja, ein Stecker, ein Stecker ist glaube ich nochmal ein kurzer Stock, glaube ich. Ist glaube ich was ganz anderes. Irgendwann bist du halt dann bei einer Staffette. Nee, bei einer Staffel. Ach, keine Ahnung. Mir egal. Furchtbar. Aber hast du dich auch mal ausgesperrt aus dem Car2Go? Das ist meine Horrorvorstellung. Ja, das habe ich auch mal. Ja, genau. Das ist jedes Mal meine Horrorvorstellung, irgendwann das Handy zu vergessen, die Schulze zu machen. Dann hört man dieses Klickgeräusch und denkt sich, oh, shit. Ich habe mich ausgesperrt aus dem Auto, habe ein Handy eingesperrt und kam nicht mehr rein, weil die Mietbehandlung endet war. Oh mein Gott. Und dann natürlich, super soziophob, will niemanden anfragen, bin zu einer Telefonzelle gelaufen. Aber was für ein Eis mehr. Der einzigen, die es noch gibt in Hamburg. Du kannst ja nichts machen, was kannst du denn machen? Du hast ja nichts, alles, alle Notfallkontakte sind auf deinem Handy. Ja, du hast keine Chance, ich bin zu einer Telefonzelle gelaufen, ich dachte mir, ich gucke mich mal um, ob ich hier eine Telefonzelle finde, zwinker, zwinker, ja da direkt neben mir einer wirklich so. Ich dachte mir so, 1991, da bist du wieder, die Telefonzelle ist da, ruf in der Auskunft an und sag, bitte verbinden Sie sich mit Car2Go und die meint so, ja klar, gerne. Aber ich merke, Sie rufen von der Telefonzelle an, da kann ich Sie leider nicht verbinden. What? Also, was ist dein Job denn eigentlich? Das ist der einzige Ort, auf dem man noch Leute verbinden muss. Also keine Chance, und dann war ich da ganz traurig, weil ich habe dann am Auto gewartet und habe gewartet, bis jemand anders das Auto mietet und dann kommt und es öffnet und dann kann ich sagen, hier, das ist mein Handy. Und dann kam jemand und meinte, hey, ich höre das Podcast-Ufo. Und ich meinte, mega geil, Alter, kann ich dein Handy benutzen, habe bei Car2Go angerufen, alles geklärt. Zack, also Shoutout an diesen einen Podcast-Ufo-Hörer, der mich da erkannt hat. Ja, Shoutout, wir helfen uns noch, wir sind zusammen. Wir wären verloren ohne euch. Völlig verloren. Könnt ihr morgen alle beim Umzug helfen? Ja, oder hat jemand einen Termin? Ich sehe es, da kommt der Kalender raus. Alle haben direkt einen Termin. Alle holen so Handy raus, nein, geht nicht.
Aber ich hätte nie im Leben jemanden gefragt, ob ich das Handy benutzen darf, aber da die Person nicht entspannt.
Nee, wirklich nicht? Nie. Aber dann hilft dir, glaube ich.
Nein, nee.
Da wollte ich auch mal so verloren, wenn du so um Reihen schaust.
Nee, das ist so, nee, ja, ich weiß, aber das ist so, da hat mich mal jemand gefragt.
Und ich denke halt immer, wenn ich ein Handy klauen würde, ich würde jemanden fragen, kann ich kurz dein Handy haben?
Und vor allem dann war es dieses, man will dann so dieses Gespräch nicht vor der Person führen, dann will man so, kann ich dein Handy haben? Ja.
Und ich so wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow und einfach geht mega weit weg und ich so okay, ich bleibe zusteden und gucke zu, wie mein Handy geklaut wird einfach.
Gut, das ist jetzt mein Leben.
Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum dann so in Rom und sowas immer noch so Taschendiebstähle passieren. Warum nicht einfach andauernd Leute kommen, die sagen, kann ich mir ein Foto von dir machen? Ja. Und dann wegrennen. Und dann wegrennen, ja. Und man immer denkt, ja, geil, das ist nicht schlecht. Aber in dem Moment, in dem sie wegrennen, noch ein Foto machen. Ja. Und dann haben sie so. Von sich so. Ich glaube. Das wäre ein Instagram-Account, dem ich folgen würde. Und es ist ja auch entsperrt. Weil Handys klaut man ja nicht mehr, weiß ich nicht, schon noch, haben ja noch Wert an sich, aber die sind ja meistens dann auch gesperrt und so und dann ist es nervig. Gerade bei Apple, glaube ich, macht es doch keinen Sinn mehr zu klauen, weil wenn du das nicht wieder freigibst, dann macht es doch, glaube ich, keinen Sinn, das wieder auszusetzen. Ich habe da keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube, es ist eine gute Message, die da rausgeht. Klaut keine Handys, macht's einfach nicht. Wenn ihr diesen Podcast aber im geklauten Handy hört, bringt es wieder zurück. Aber ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee, Müll in einem Car-to-Go zu entsorgen, weil ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich Müll unterbringen soll, der gross ist. Und dann habe ich mich daran erinnert, dass ich früher, weil man hatte ja als Kind ultra-weirde Freunde auch. Also irgendwie hat man das so hingenommen, dass man ultra-strange Freunde hat, weil so der wohnte halt neben mir. Ja, meistens wohnen in der Nähe. Heute ist auch halt mal ein Kriterium so. Ja, genau. Die sind intellektuell, mit denen kann man lange reden, haben schöne Wohnungen, man will gerne mit den Zeit verbringen, sind wahnsinnig lustig. Man hat sehr viele Kriterien, so erwachsenen, dumme erwachsene Kriterien, aber damals war einfach nur wohnen in der Nähe. Ja, genau, wohnen in der Nähe und vor allem auch so dieses, ja, wir kennen uns halt aus dem Kindergarten. Ja. So dieses, wir haben eine Geschichte miteinander. Und eigentlich auch, je weirder, desto besser. Total. Man will halt, man will halt so ein bisschen on the edge of the seat sein. Und dieser eine ubide Freund, und dann lernt man ja so ganz andere Welten kennen irgendwie so, weil man kennt, also Eltern kennt man nur diese zwei Menschen aus seinem eigenen Haus und dann kommt man und sieht andere Eltern und denkt sich, wie andere, was soll das? Und dann war das so ganz klar, ja, wir haben Sperrmüll und die haben ihren Sperrmüll im Garten vergraben. Vergraben? Und es war so... Wie muss man sich den Garten denn vorstellen? Das war ein ganz normaler Garten, aber dann war es selbstverständlich, dass da ein Loch gegraben wird, wo die so alte Stangen und Sachen reingeballert haben. Die haben dann nicht danach den Garten wiederhergestellt. Also da haben wir Erdeweh drauf und dann haben wir Rollrasen und dann war ja schick. Ich glaube schon, dass das einfach weg musste, einfach so. Und ich kann's bis heute, ich hab das so als Kind so, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm schlecht. Loch ausheben, Müll rein, Loch zu. Gibt Sinn, klar.
Also klar, ja, mach weiter, mach weiter, mach weiter, mach weiter, kein Ding. Ich gucke nur zu, ich gucke nur zu.
Ich hätte gern Eis, aber ich will auch einfach wieder hin. Zwanzig Jahre später denkt man sich, what, aber eigentlich eine gute Idee, weil der Nachmieter irgendwann denkt sich, findet dann irgendwie Sachen, sind eine alte Waschmaschine oder so. Mega. Na gut, vor allem, also, ja, ich check halt, ich check halt, ich verstehe halt nicht, weil wenn so ein Archäologe so eine alte gallische Siedlung findet, dann ist die immer im Boden drin. Ich frag mich, wieso ist die im Boden drin, warum ist die nicht oben drauf, weil ...
Also ist es dann so, ah, die ist alt, also schluckt der Boden die auf. Und ich denke mir so, warum muss man graben, um dann auf Erdgeschoss, ich raff's nicht, aber deswegen denke ich mir... Ich glaube, Schlammlawinen. Und dann, ja, Schlammlawinen, wo sind die Schlammlawinen, warum erleben wir die so nicht? Aber da ist es vielleicht so, dass irgendwann in tausend Jahren diese Waschmaschine wieder so aus dem Boden rauskommt, weil tektonische Plattenverschiebung, niemand weiß warum, aber es ist einfach, ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Aber eigentlich ganz geil, weil das sind ja Dinge, die auch bei uns dann gefunden, von unserer Generation gefunden werden, weil irgendwann irgendwie so ein Elektrosturm über die Erde fegt und dann alle Beweise von unserer Existenz, von unseren Handys und so löscht und so dann und die Generation nach uns finden dann so eine Waschmaschine und Eisenstangen im Garten vergraben von dieser Familie und freuen sich dann und denken, was heißt Bosch? Was ist Bosch? Warum haben die Menschen damals Bosch angebetet? Bosch war wahrscheinlich ein Herrscher, ein mächtiger Herrscher, der Leuten Arbeit geschenkt hat. Vielleicht war es auch ein Mörder, der halt da in der Waschmaschine was drin hatte oder so. Weiss man nicht. Weiss man nicht. Bosch. Niemand weiss es. Was ist Bosch eigentlich? Guter Name. Richtig guter Name. Und gute Serie. Vielleicht. Wir haben schon so oft Werbung für Bosch gebaut, und das ist immer wieder einfach ein guter Name. Bosch. Klingt's gern. Ja, klingt auch gut. Was auch Fußballtrainer heißt Bosch. Was machst du mit deinem Müll? Wo tust du deinem Müll hin? Mein Müll? Wenn du mal so ein richtig sperriges Ding hast, so einen richtigen... Ja, wahrscheinlich Werkstoffhof oder Verschenken. Oder Keller einfach dann. Keller und ausziehen. Ja, Keller habe ich. Und dann einfach schön den Keller und regelmäßig umziehen einfach, damit man es einfach hinter sich wird. Nee, der wird ja kontrolliert wahrscheinlich bei der Wohnungsübergabe, das ist ein Problem. Aber wahrscheinlich einfach... Also kann man Dinge einfach auf die Strasse stellen, zum Verschenken draufschreiben oder muss man das vorher beim Sperrmüll anmelden? Ich weiß nicht genau, was da die Regeln sind, ob man so eine Matratze einfach hinlegen kann. Was darf man? Was darf man? Das ist eigentlich eine gute Frage. Kann jemand eine Liste machen von allen Dingen, die man darf? Die andere Idee, das kommt von der anderen Seite, alle Dinge, die man nicht darf. Okay, oder wir treffen uns in der Mitte und wir machen eine Liste mit Dingen, von denen man denkt, dass man sie nicht darf, man sie aber tatsächlich darf. Das wäre eine Liste, die ich mir angucken würde. Das wäre ein geiles Gesetzbuch. So vielleicht so, ey, vielleicht ist es vollkommen legal, einfach seinen kompletten Müll einfach direkt auf den Marktplatz zu legen. Das darf man, darf man einfach. Das Gesundheitsministerium sagt nein. Ja, vielleicht darf man auch einfach, vielleicht darf man Menschen morden, wenn er halb so gross ist wie man selbst. Einfach so nicht wirklich? Das wüsste ich gar nicht. Das darf man? Ja, ja, klar, dürfen Sie, klar, kein Problem. Okay, okay, kein Problem, muss man da nicht machen. Man darf Fledermäuse an der Leine halten. Ja, genau. Aber gibt's da Grenzen eigentlich bei Tieren? Nee, ja. Steht da irgendwo, naja, steht da irgendwo, da dürfen keine Leoparden, da wird da keine Liste mit Tieren stehen, die man nicht halten darf. Doch, ich glaube schon. Da wird eine Liste stehen mit Dingen, die man halten darf, wahrscheinlich. Ja, es ist wahrscheinlich kürzer, wahrscheinlich kürzer, alle Tiere aufzulösten, die man haben darf. Wlen Sie die hier, Hunde, Katzen, Fische, that's basically it. Und Schildkröten, wenn es unbedingt sein muss. Wenn es unbedingt sein muss, muss aber auch nicht sein. Wenn das Kind sehr lange quengelt. Ich glaube, ich könnte keine Schildkröte haben, weil ich dem Drang nicht widerstehen könnte, die Schildkröte einfach auf ihren Rücken zu bringen. Ach so. Und ich sag nicht, dass ich's mache und ich sag, dass ich deswegen keine Schildkröte habe. Es ist nur der Drang, vielleicht liegt's daran, dass ich meiner Kindheit so bei Mario gespielt habe, ich weiss es nicht. Aber wenn ich diese Schildkröte sehen würde ... Dreh ihn auch. Und ich würde gut zu ihr sein, ich würde nett zu ihr sein, ich würde sie streicheln, bringt das was ... Nee, ich würde sie drehen. Ich würde sie so einen Kreisel drehen. Genau, ich würde sie erst auf dem Rücken legen und dann so Breakdance und dann so zack und dann einfach sagen und deswegen habe ich keine Haustiere. Aber ich habe auch keine Haustiere. Und dann so Bayblade mässig. Zack, aber komm, ihr würdet es euch angucken, ihr würdet es euch angucken. Hundertprozentig, hundertprozentig. Ja, so roten, roten, kumann hat das schon mal gemacht oder sowas. Aber kann man… Die Seiten, die es nicht mehr gibt, gibt's noch?
Aber hat nicht mal aus Gag jemand seiner Schildkröte einfach den Panzer abgenommen, um zu sehen, wie die einfach so 100 kmh schnell ist? Einfach so zip, einfach plötzlich, Alter, das ist viel geiler. Was ist die so, what? Viel besser so. Weiss man gar nicht. Nee, ich glaube, weil da Organe drin hängen. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Ich glaube, die Grosse der Organe sind so verschmolzen mit dem Panzer. Ja, ja, die sind halt angeschmolzen, so an die Decke wie Stuck hängen da die ganzen Organe von der Schildkröte oben drin. Das ist die Lunge da oben, hier, da ist der Ding, Dünndarm. Und am Rand so ein geiles Chesterfield, so. Und es riecht auch so verqualmt, weil es sich immer so reinzieht und dann noch... Ja, jetzt ziehe ich mich zurück. Crips Schildkröte? MTV Crips Schildkröte, so eine Schildkröte zeigt den Innenraum so, ja, hier habe ich einen Kühlschrank, hier, guck mir mal alles rein, hier Kuschelecke so nebenbei ein bisschen, hier der Sofaecke, richtig gut. Wahrscheinlich einfach, das ist alles voll mit meinen Organen. Ja, genau, hier unten ist meine Leber, Dünndarm, das Milz. Und nächste Woche bei Tiercrips, Schnecken. Ja, Schnecken. Hier sind alles meine Organe, so, da hinten auch. Nächste Woche Gürteltier. Ja, es ist ein Wohnwagen, man muss sich da so reindrehen erst. Wir haben kein Haus, sagt das Gürteltier. Wir haben kein Haus, wir haben Anhänger. Wir sind Anhänger. Gibt's Tiere mit Anhängern eigentlich? Nee, aber es gibt diese Echsen, die Schwänze abwerfen können, um Feinde zu verwirren. Hat das jemals funktioniert eigentlich? Dass das nach 200 Millionen Jahren Evolution immer noch klappt, dass nicht die Jäger irgendwann sagen, nur übrigens, by the way, ganz kurz, wenn du ein Tier fressen willst und es in den Schwanz abwirft, sei nicht verwirrt, tschau, mach's gut und schon ist das Problem gelöst. Ja, aber warum sind die Tiere verwirrt? Oder essen die dann den Schwanz und sind dann erstmal happy? Wen die nun Snack, suchen die so einen Salzstange. Sind zum Knabbern, für den kleinen Hunger, vielleicht brauchen die gar nichts. Und verlieren dann alle Echsen, viele Fragen, und wenn dann alle Echsen gleichzeitig fliehen, verlieren die alle ihren Schwanz? Nee, die sprechen sich ab. Sprechen sie ab, weil ist ja auch für alle nervig, weil wenn die jetzt alle, dann sind ja alle angreifbar, wenn die alle nachwachsen. Nee, das rotiert so, Montag, Mittwoch ist Udo dran, Dienstag, Freitag ist Karl dran und einfach, wenn wir heute angegriffen werden, bitte schmeißt du deinen Schwanz ab, ich hab noch letzte Woche schon, ja, nicht mein Problem. Schwanzsichtsystem, ja, ja, macht schon Sinn. Nicht mein Problem. Okay, dann wirft man das ab, einer, und dann stürzt sich das Raubtier dann da rauf. Nee, rutscht dann so auf dem Schwanz auf. So Evolution, yes, einfach, guter Abwehrmechanismus. Nee, weil es dann denkt, jetzt ist es zerbrochen, tot oder was? Ich habe wirklich, Stefan, du rufst mich immer nachts an. Wie weisst du das? Und du stellst mir Fragen. Wie sagst du mir mal, was es denn ist? Warum haben Schlangen nicht wie ein Katamaran so zwei Schlangen dran, so Doppelschlange? Stefan, ich versuche seit einer Stunde einzuschlafen, du rufst mich an. Du hast gesagt, ich kann mich mit Problemen immer an dich wenden. Ja, ich kann es dir leider nicht beantworten. Ich kann es dir wirklich nicht sagen, leider. Oh, aber letztens, tatsächlich, ich hatte einen Gruselmoment, ich hatte einen richtigen Gruselmoment. Ja, also, muss ich mal. Ja, und es ist immer interessant, wie man auf Gruselmomente reagiert. Ich lag im Bett. Ja, ich schreie meistens spitz und denke dann immer, oh, so sollte man nicht schreien, weil wenn ich sterbe, wenn ich sterbe, das ist wie dieses, ja.
Gib mir mal einen spitzen Schrei, wie, also jetzt mal ganz realistisch, ja, zu hoch, da müsstest du eigentlich so ein Schreitraining, ja, ich würde gern für den Fall, dass mich jemand mit einer Axt begegnet und mich töten will, dass ich zumindest am Ende noch so ein Oh, geben kann und kein, ah! Ein Kollege von mir hat mich mal erschrocken, bei dem waren wir abends, sassen dann draußen und er hat sich, wollte mich erschrecken und hat sich dann immer in der dunklen Wohnung hat er sich vor die Glastür gestellt. Und ich saß halt genau daneben, also saß da neben der Tür und habe ihn die ganze Zeit nicht gesehen. Und ich habe mich aber auch nicht gefragt, wo er ist, weil er hat ewig gewartet, bis ich nach rechts gucke und alle haben schon gecheckt am Tisch, ich habe mich nicht geschnallt und dann habe ich drüber geguckt und habe mich unglaublich erschrocken und ich habe das schon wieder vergessen in dem Moment, aber für den Kollegen, Silvester hat er gesagt, das war der lustigste Moment des Jahres. Oh, aber vor oder nach 0 Uhr an Silvester? Vor 0 Uhr. Er hat gesagt, das wäre der beste Moment des Jahres gewesen für ihn, einer der lustigsten Momente, wo ich den schon wieder fast wieder fast vergessen. Ich dachte mir, aber cool, dass ich in der besten Liste vorkomme. Aber auch irgendwie traurig für dein Jahr. Nein, Erschrecken macht Spaß, weil man sieht einfach nie so dumm aus, wenn man sich erschrickt. Es ist ja auch die Schildkröte so ein bisschen. Man macht einfach ein dummes Geräusch, weil es einfach egal ist. Aber da müssen wir dran arbeiten. Ich versuche dir jetzt mal jede Woche zu erschrecken, damit du dich vorbereiten kannst und sagen, wenn ich erschreckt werde, habe ich ein tiefes Geräusch. Okay, was ist denn dein, was ist dein Horrormoment? Mein grosser Moment war, ich lag im Bett, wollte gerade einschlafen und plötzlich geht das Licht an. In meinem Zimmer. Geht schlagartiges Licht an. Holy shit. Halt, ich hab ... Da würde man normalerweise jetzt in so einem wachen Moment ganz seriös reagieren. Ja, wahrscheinlich hat sie irgendwie Alexa das Licht angemacht oder so. Stehen wir auf, machen es wieder aus, legen uns hin. Aber so geht man ja nachts dann nicht. Nee, ich habe weder Alexa noch, und vor allem, ich bin, was in eine Richtung geht, absolut der Schlechteste, den es gibt. Ich habe ein Licht pro Raum, das war's. Ich habe keine Lampe, Nachtisch, irgendwie so gelande. Ich habe keine Lampe so gesagt, als wäre es ein Gadget, was man … Ja, oder dann diese …
Was so ein Luxury-Gadget, was man nicht braucht.
Ich habe so eine Lampe nicht, ich habe so einen Kühlschrank, wie man so neumodern gerne sagt, habe ich so einen Backofen nicht.
Ja.
Oh, die jungen Leute mit ihren Mülleimern. Oder diese drei immer kleiner werdenden Kugeln, die dann leuchten, habe ich alles nicht. Das verstehe ich, das kannst du so sagen. Und dann wirklich, und vor allem dann, das ist ja dann ganz geil, weil ich glaube, man reagiert in Extremsituationen anders als man es erwartet. Du kennst ja solche Schockmomente eher aus Horrorfilmen, wo dann, ah, großer Schrei, Flucht oder so. Ich glaube, wenn wirklich, wenn wirklich irgendwas Schlimmes passieren würde, würde man wahrscheinlich nicht so reagieren, genauso wie ich in der Situation, nicht geschrien habe oder so, sondern mein Reflex war, okay, ich bin bereit. Echt jetzt? Dann bin ich so, okay, was los? So als würde so ein Spotlight auf mich sehen, so, okay, ich bin bereit. Und erst ab dann so, Moment, was ist hier gerade ... Hast du geschlafen?
Ich habe noch nicht geschlafen. Du warst wach. Ich war wach. Was war dein Zustand, dein geistiger Zustand? Warst du kurz vor dem Einschlafen, warst du noch am Prübeln, meditieren? Ja, so mittel auf dem Weg. Meditieren. So, ich war noch in der Phase, wo ich mich selber fertig mache und bereue Dinge, die ich den letzten Tag getan habe. Okay. In der Phase war ich noch. Okay. Ich war noch nicht in der Weckdös-Phase und war dann wirklich so Licht an und ich so, okay, erst mal, ich bin bereit. Und dann dann kam erst der Gruselmoment und was ihr vielleicht wissen müsst, was ihr vielleicht als treue Podcast-UFO-Hörer wisst, ist, dass in der Wohnung in Hamburg, wo das passiert ist, meine Wohnung in Hamburg hat in jedem Raum einen Dimmer. In jedem Raum, es gibt keinen einzigen Schalter. Warum sagen alle ja? Ja, ja, ja, kenn ich. Als hätten sie jetzt schon geschnallt, Sherlock's, was passiert. Ja, aber es ist wirklich so, es ist wirklich ... Ich hab noch nicht genug Hinweise. Es gibt in keinem Raum einen klassischen Aus-An-Schalter, sondern jeder Raum gedimmt. Und klar, irgendwie schläfts mal, ja, irgendwie ein bisschen durch angenehme Stimmung, Wohnzimmer, aber halt auch ... Weil da was passiert, flohen. Ja, okay, halt auch, halt auch ... Du schildkröten drehst, ne? Ein schönes bisschen dimmlicht dafür. Ich mag's romantisch auf YouPorn, so, es ist okay. Aber wenn du ... Ja, nee, man muss sich auch was Gutes tun. Aber vor allem, ich hab diese Lichtdimmer in jedem Raum, auch im Bad. Und auch in der Küche habe ich überall diese Lichtdimmer. Im Bad. Ich weiss nicht, was da falsch gelaufen ist. Wobei im Bad, das macht schon Sinn. Und das war dann vielleicht auch der Ursprung, warum es dann passiert ist. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, man würde anders reagieren. Nee, weißt, weißt, weißt, weißt, weißt, du hast noch nicht erklärt. Ja, nee, ich weiss bis heute nicht, was passiert ist. Es ist einfach schlagartig angegangen, das Licht, aber wirklich voll. Weißt du, was ich machen würde? Ich würde erst Augen aufmachen, Angst bekommen, weil man merkt ja auch, wenn die Augen zu hat, dass es hell geworden ist, ganz toll, würde aber ganz ruhig liegen bleiben, um die Augen wieder zu machen. Ja, und gucken, ob es hilft, ob du damit das Licht wieder auskriegst. Weil das kann man doch bei Albträumen, wenn man denkt, da ist jetzt ein Mörder im Zimmer oder so, wenn man vom Albtraum aufwacht. Ich bin dann wie angespannt und alles ist wie eingefroren und dann mache ich die Augen, presse ich zu und man denkt, wenn ich die Gefahr nicht sehen kann, kann sie mich auch nicht sehen. Ja, und der Typ mit dem so über mir, und er will ja auch irgendwie, dass man schreit oder sowas. Ja, weiß nicht. Und wenn die Dinge fallen, will ich ihm nicht tun. Aber mein komplettes Notfallprotokoll war, aufstehen, in den Gang gucken, weil wenn da niemand ist, dann ist niemand da. Einfach so, ist halt niemand da. Hast du spontan eine Waffe gesucht oder sowas? Nee, nee, nee. Oder die Pringlesdose vom Bett? Ich habe tatsächlich immer, weil ich mir manchmal vorstelle, dass ich Einbrecher dann besiege oder wenn irgendwas kommt. Womit? Deswegen, ja womit, womit, was habe ich in meiner Wohnung um... Den Schaumfinger von den Mets. Es ist tatsächlich, es ist, es ist die Stange vom Staubsauger. Wow, gar nicht doof! Die abgeschraubt ... abgeschraubt von dem ... aber ich staubsaug nie, sind wir mal ehrlich. Was ich manchmal mache, ist, ich räum die Staubflocken weg beiseite, so diese Staubmäuse räum ich weg. Nicht aufsaugen, nur zur Seite. Ist eher ein Umsortieren als ein Säuber. Ja, es ist ... man fühlt sich aufgeräumt, es ist aufgeräumt. Man ist auch aufgeräumt. Hat seinen Platz. Ist halt sauerdreckig, aber es ist aufgeräumt. Ja, aber das ist deswegen, na was ist denn Staubsaugen, du tust den Dreck von einem Ohr zum anderen. Ja. Der ist auch nicht weg, so Dreck ist ja nie weg, das ist ja nur ein Umstrukturieren. Ich habe diese, ich habe diese Stange und ich glaube, damit könnte ich jemanden besiegen, egal wer da kommt auf mich zu. Ich glaube, du siehst auch gar nicht so gar nicht so falsch, weil die ist ja aus massivem … Massivem Stahl. … Erz. Ja, ja. Ich glaube aber auch, vor allem das Nächste, was ich war … der nächste Punkt, an dem ich war, ermordet zu werden, war in der Abifahrt in Tschechien, als unsere Nachbarn im Nachbarnhaus, wir hatten da so Häuser mit und so Doppelbetten, als die sich entschlossen haben, mitten in der Nacht in unser Haus einzubrechen und uns zu erschrechen im Schlafzimmer. Und mein Kumpel und ich, dann stand der mit einem Besen, mit einem Besen über uns und wollte uns so abbesen. Klassisch. Ja, klassischer Angriff, klassischer Abifahrt. Wollen wir sie abbesen? Ja, komm, lass damit. Genau, das war der, ja, wir könnten sie abbesen. Also, quick brainstorm. Ja, okay,, ein bisschen was vorbereiten, also entweder abbesen, klar, Klassiker, oder halt Edding, irgendwie Edding, noch auf die Stirn malen. Was wir auf jeden Fall machen, wir tun Schuh in den Kühlschrank. Das machen wir auf, das ist safe, glaube ich, da müssen wir nicht drüber reden, haben sie tatsächlich gemacht. Was? Haben sie tatsächlich gemacht. Was machen die heutzutage? Bumsen, Fledermäuse und bringen einen Virus in den Weg. Ja genau, genau so. Jonas, du im Fernsehen! Ja, mein Gott, man ist einsam im Dschungel, das ist schwierig. Aber die kamen da, haben uns abgebest und mein Kumpel wacht auf und weißt du, es hätte wie ich sagen, dass er gerade ermordet wurde. Und er nur so, what the fuck? Das war war seine Reaktion, kein Schreien, kein Sondern so, what the fuck, einfach so, was passiert denn? Ich glaube, wenn nachts ein Mörder vor mir steht, würde ich auch einfach sagen so, ja bitte? Einfach weil ich glaube, du reagierst anders, als du denkst, dass du reagierst. Ich glaube, ich würde ganz anders reagieren. Das ist eine tolle Geschichte, die Bill Hader mal in der Late Night Show erzählt hat, wo die so einen Mega- so einen Prop-Meister hatten, also jemand, der sehr gute Requisiten macht und der hat mal lange mit so einem Messer rumgespielt, einem echten Messer und dann kam ein Kollege von denen an und hat gesagt, ey, kannst du mit dem Messer spielen, das ist doch Quatsch, ich verletze dich, dann er hat gesagt, okay, weird, okay, mache ich euch auf, wobei es auch weird, dass er mit dem Messer spielt, davon abgesehen, und dann sind wir so ein Prop-Guy gegangen und der Prop-Guy hat denen halt so ein megageiles Messer, das gleiche Messer gebaut, aber halt so filmmessermäßig, dass wenn du ihn stichst, die Klingel verschwindet. Und dann kam irgendwann dieser Kollege, der hat wieder angefangen zu spielen, haben die dem dann gegeben, er hat wieder angefangen damit zu spielen, dann kam dieser anxious Kollege wieder an und dann hat er dem das reingerangen, das Prop-Messer und das ist halt, also da sind Pranks dann auch irgendwann zu gut. Ja, zu lustig. Und der Mensch, der dachte, er wird jetzt abgestochen, hatte in einem ähnlichen Moment wie dein Kumpel dann, in dem Moment, er hat einfach gesagt, why? Ja, das würde man sagen, das würde man sagen, why? Ja genau, weil du bist ja in dem Moment, ich glaube auch dieses Schreien, das kennt man ja aus Filmen.
Aus Filmen kennst du dieses Schreien und so, das ist natürlich auch ein Reflex auf eine Art, aber ich glaube, dass in den meisten Momenten anders reagiert.
Total. Warum? Warum? Sorry, aber irgendwas willkürliches.
Deswegen will ich ja nicht, dass Fotos davon existiert, wie ich dann ermordet werde.
Nee, das ist, glaube ich, das Schlimmste. Wovon man sich aber freuen kann, wovon Footage entsteht, ist einer unserer, ich würde mal sagen, Top vier Kontinente dieser Erde. Ich weiss ja immer schon, was für eine Rubrik amoderiert wird, so grob. Und diese Brücken, die du immer schlägst, sind bahnbrechend. Ich würde mal sagen, es gibt gute Kontinente und es gibt schlechte Kontinente auf dieser Erde. Nenn mal Top fünf Kontinente. Ähm, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, Platz vier ... Ozeanien. Ja, ist schwierig, aber jetzt wird es kritisch. Egal, wovor wir eigentlich kommen sollten. Australien kann man unter dem Bus werfen, das interessiert niemanden. Danach wird es kritisch. Natürlich unser großer Lieblingskontinent, Afrika. Wir haben schon viel, viel, viel gelernt über diesen fantastischen Kontinent Afrika, viele, viele Länder erkundet, und wir wollen das heute auch einmal live stattfinden lassen, denn es ist etwas passiert.
Es gab nämlich ein Nachspiel zu einer Folge.
Es gab eine kleine Katastrophe, muss man einfach sagen.
Es gab eine kleine Katastrophe zu einer Folge Antenne Afrika, aber dazu würde ich sagen, gehen wir erstmal in die Rubrik.
Meine Damen und Herren, hier ist Antenne Afrika.
Ja, Dankeschön.
Willst du etwas machen? Timing? Hier ist Antenne Afrika und wir begrüssen auf der Bühne Yannick! Yannick ist da! Yannik! Mega! Applaus für Jannik! Jannik ist heute hier! Hallo Jannik! Hallo, freut mich! Hallo, hi! Komm mal in die Mitte, komm am besten rein. Hier ist Jannik, Jannik ist unser… Was ist hier eigentlich auf der Bühne eigentlich? Das ist ein Glück, das ist nicht so richtig. Hast du wieder rumgebildet, du hast einfach nur von A nach B den Schraub wiedergebracht. Hallo Jannik, erst mal hi! Hi, ja, cool, dass ich hier sein darf. Freut uns sehr, wir müssen ganz kurz mal erklären, wer du bist, falls manche vielleicht jetzt Yannick noch nicht kennen.
Yannick ist der junge Mann, der uns den Beitrag aus Namibia gebracht hat, unser Mann aus Namibia, und er hat auch dafür gesorgt, dass wir im namibischen Radio stattfinden. Genau, erklär es mal. Genau, ich habe ein FSJ gemacht in Namibia und weil ich dachte, FSJ ja, aber Menschen muss nicht unbedingt sein, muss nichts mit Menschen zu tun haben. Aber in Namibia gibt es sehr viele Menschen. Ja, da gibt es sehr viele Menschen, aber ich habe da zwei Millionen, also für ein Land, das dreimal so groß ist wie Deutschland. Ja, genau, und ich habe gedacht, FSJ ja, aber mit Menschen nicht unbedingt, aber in einem Radiosender würde ich da arbeiten. Und genau, da habe ich das letzte halbe Jahr gearbeitet und habe eine Jugendsendung bekommen, die ich dort selber moderieren durfte, weil die Kollegen alle sehr, sehr alt sind tatsächlich. Also hat man dir zu viel Macht gegeben, würdest du sagen? Ja, sehr, also definitiv. Okay. Weil, also ich musste da auch nicht irgendwie unter Beweis stellen, dass ich das hinkriege oder so. Genau wie heute Abend auch nicht. Exakt, ja, das zieht sich durch mein Leben. Genau, und dann, wenn ich im Urlaub war, wurde mir gesagt, ich soll was vorbereiten und dann dachte ich, ja, ich kann ja auch einfach einen Podcast reinziehen. Und dann habe ich mit Florentin geschrieben und gefragt, ob das in Ordnung ist, dass ich den dort abspiele. Genau, das ist ein deutschsprachiger Radiosender, weil es da noch Deutsche gibt. Und dann habe ich, hast du gesagt, ja, wir lieben Namibia und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, Das haben wir gesagt, das war unser Wording. Ja, und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie sieht es andersrum aus, also wie seid ihr in Namibia angekommen und, um es mal vorsichtig zu formulieren, es ist glaube ich eine einseitige Liebe. Oh, ganz kurz. Ja. Also du hast, was machst du sonst in diesem Radio? Da spielst du einfach Beiträge? Musik, viel Musik, viel Musik und ab und zu rede ich über Sachen. Du hast vorher aber keine Beiträge wie Podcast zum Beispiel geschrieben. Nee, nee, nee. Das heißt, jetzt kam zum ersten Mal wurde Namibia mit dem Podcast-UFO-Podcast-Projekt konfrontiert? Das war auch, glaube ich, der erste Podcast, der überhaupt jemals in Namibia gehört wurde, weil ich, also die Leute dort sind nicht so vertraut mit diesem neuen Medium. Ja, okay. Das heißt, du hast eine Folge, welche Folge hast du gespielt? Sehr viele. Also ich war lange im Urlaub. Ja, aber ich fand das super im Himmel, ist es mir so unangenehm jetzt schon. Kannst du mal vielleicht ganz grob sagen, ich weiss, eine sehr persönliche Frage, die niemand von uns gerne beantwortet, aber kannst du vielleicht grob sagen, wie viele Hörer ihr bei diesem Radio habt? Ja, also es gibt nur 20.000 Leute, die überhaupt Deutsch sprechen, das heisst, so viele werden es nicht sein, und genau das ist eben das Thema. Ich war sehr froh, dass ich den Podcast gespielt habe. Ich dachte immer, niemand hört mir zu, aber ... Weil du nie Feedback bekommen hast. Nie Feedback, weder von meinen Kollegen. Aber jetzt hast du Feedback bekommen. Da habe ich Feedback bekommen. Die Leute haben auf einmal angefangen, sich zu melden, und zwar vor allem, weil ihr sehr oft, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ihr sagt wohl oft Fuck. Und das... Naja, jetzt aber auch nicht so oft. Nee, aber den Namibian, den deutschen Namibian zu oft. Zu oft Fuck, das kam nicht so gut an. Das war aber alles noch, ja, da... Das ging noch. Die haben auch nicht die Beziehung zwischen uns verstanden, die meinten, ja, kannst du vielleicht deinen Kollegen mal sagen, dass sie ein bisschen weniger Fakt sagen sollen, ja, jetzt habe ich es mitgeteilt. Aber eine Folge kam tatsächlich besonders wenig gut an, es war Folge 195, Pufo, Hub, genau, es ging um Pornosender und um Pornoseiten und das hatte eklatante Folgen.
Moment, ganz kurz, kurze Frage mal an Florentin. Wusstest du bei der Folge, als wir die aufgenommen haben, Pornhub, Pufo-Hub, wusstest du, dass wir da in Namibia laufen? Ja, ich hab's grob, ja, so halb. Also wir hatten ja geschrieben und Janik meinte so, ja, ich spiele euch da so, aber ich dachte auch, dass das irgendwie nach dem eigentlichen Programm so nachts, so von vier bis sechs Uhr, brauchst du halt noch was, damit du nicht Stille senden musst, sendest du halt irgendwie unseren Podcast. Liebe, liebe Geschworn, ich will gerne die Frage wiederholen. Sie wussten also, während der Folge Pufo Hub, wo es primär um Pornosender ging, Pornoseiten ging. Wir sind ja mittlerweile, und das vergessen manche auch oft, wir sind ja auch in Australien zu hören. Also es gibt auch einen australischen Radiosender, der uns immer noch im Programm hat. Und das wusstest du, hast du gerade, das in Australien wird es gemacht? Spinnst du gerade eigentlich? Jesus Christ! Also das war tatsächlich, also mit so einem Feedback habe ich nicht gerechnet, also da war wirklich, also der deutschsprachige Teil von Namibia, der stand in Flammen. Das war wirklich, also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch an die Erdogan-Affäre vom Neo-Magazin erinnert, ich glaube, das ist etwa vergleichbar, im deutschsprachigen Teil von Namibia war das etwa so, so, so gross war das. Und ja, es haben sich Wohlhörer beschwert, ich musste zu meiner Chefin und darüber sprechen, die hat mir gesagt, das nächste Mal, wenn du nicht selber die Sendung moderierst, vielleicht einfach Musik reinmachen. Das haben die Rentner von Thais auch gesagt. Es ist ein Phenomenon. Ja, und ich habe tatsächlich auch, kann ich vielleicht mal vortragen, ich habe auch, mir wurden E-Mails zugetragen, die von, die von, nicht von Hörern, sondern von anderen Kollegen, die aber mit mir oder mit der Sendung nicht so vertraut waren. Okay. Genau, die E-Mail einer Kollegin, der betreff eine eindringliche Frage. Selten gut solche E-Mails. Es sind Klagen aus der Hörerschaft über die Jugendsendung hereingekommen, also meine Sendung, genau. Die vom vergangenen Donnerstag habe ich mir angehört, die Sprache ist tatsächlich nicht vertretbar. Auch nicht wie zum Beispiel Klassiker heruntergemacht werden. Ich glaube, da ging es irgendwie darum, um das von … So geht's mal heute mal. Ja, ich weiß nicht, von alten … Komponisten. Komponisten. Aber das haben sie … Moment, das war Blöthofen, ne, das war die Folge … Ach Gott, meine Güte! Ja, das … Blöthofen und dumm Vinci, was haben die … Das Thema Porno brachten die beiden Moderatoren auch an. Meines Erachtens kann eine derartige Sendung schon mal laufen, damit sich die Hörer ein Bild von dem machen können, was man lieber nicht machen sollte und um eine Diskussion anzuregen. Wir dürfen gesendet werden als Negativbeispiel. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, jetzt geht's weiter, jetzt geht's weiter.
Das war, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, auch das Ziel der beiden Moderatoren.
So, so, da wird …
Wir wollten abschrecken, durch das Negativbeispiel. Ja, ja, ja, ja, der war super, dödödödöm, ist doch geil!
Noch einmal zurück zur Sprache, der Rundfunk hat bestimmt nicht die Aufgabe zu fördern,
womit zum Beispiel auf dem Schulhof herumgeschmissen wird. Ferner sollten wir uns in Namibia nicht zu sehr an den derzeitigen Gepflogenheiten in Deutschland orientieren. Na so! Sie denken, sie ist das Bessere! Augenscheinlich. Das war nicht das Ziel von Lande in Afrika, das wir jetzt gegen Namibia.
Naja, es ist der deutschsprachige Teil von Namibia, das sind glaube ich schon nochmal, ähm, weiss ich, ja. Hey, hey, hey, nee, wir können, ja, ja, alles gut. Die haben Afrika ihr Land geklaut und soll jetzt besser sein als wir, oder was? Nein, das ist nicht meine Meinung, ich lese ja nur vor. Also sorry. Aber das war die eine Rückmeldung, die mir zugetragen wurde, das war die positivere. Okay, komm, hit it, komm, bring es hinter dir. Okay, okay, okay, eine kurze SMS in der Sendung von Janik, falsch geschrieben, wie immer, werden Pornoseiten empfohlen, das geht eindeutig zu weit, Unverantwortlich, gestern wurden Zeichen mit Finger als Autofahrer erklärt. Das war irgendwie diese Anekdote, wo du den Stinkefinger gezeigt hast, den Mittelfinger gezeigt hast, in einem Affekt. Und der Kollege traut sich auch gar nicht, Mittelfinger irgendwie auszuschreiben. Es ist wirklich das Zeichen mit dem Finger als Autofahrer.
Und dabei tauchte auch das F-Wort auf.
Nun zum wiederholten Male.
Bin ich der Einzige, der sich darüber aufregt?
Das soll die Sprache der Jugend sein?
Wenn ja, dann wäre das ein Armutszeugnis für unseren Sender. Wir haben auch Verantwortung und einen Auftrag. Vielen Dank an Namibia für dieses ehrliche Feedback. Ist fair, muss man mit klarkommen. Ist fair, ich finde, wir können davon lernen. Und ja, hier unsere tiefste Entschuldigung an das Land Namibia für das, was wir angerichtet haben. Das ist unverzeihlich. Also Mittelfinger zeigen und Fax sagen, das geht gar nicht. Wir möchten uns ... Das F-Wort. Das F-Wort und den Finger. Geht gar nicht. Und ja, ganz kurz eine Sache. Als du mir geschrieben hast, dachte ich, du seist in Namibia. Das war ich. Das warst du damals auch. Genau, bis Sonntag und … Bis das passiert ist. Und dann wurde er nach Hause geschickt. Nein, genau, bis Sonntag war ich in Namibia, jetzt war gerade noch das Abschlussseminar in der Nähe von Berlin, deswegen bin ich heute hier. Und genau, heute ist tatsächlich der letzte Tag von meinem FSJ und deswegen hat sich das ganz gut angeboten. Wow, ja dann mega geil. Vielen Dank, Yannick. Vielen, vielen Dank, Yannick, unser Mann ehemals in Namibia, vielen, vielen Dank und du richtest das Yannick aus Namibia, meine Damen und Herren! Oh mein Gott! Wow! Wow! Oh mein Gott! Ja, zu Recht, also wirklich zu Recht. Das ist einfach ... Ja, das war's, das war Antenafrika. Ja, war's das Antenafrika? Das war Antenafrika. Das ist vorbei jetzt. Ja, der Jingle fühlt sich jetzt auch ... würde sich auch falsch an. Es fühlt sich ein bisschen falsch an, ja. Es wäre jetzt auch komisch, jetzt einfach wieder Na Zigonja zu singen, Baba Gitti Baba, Sidi Boo … Wo wir bis heute nicht wissen, was Na Zigonja eigentlich bedeutet. Wahrscheinlich irgendwie was ganz, ganz Furchtbares, vielleicht Mittelfinger oder so. Fick euch, fick euch. Vor allem, ey, du, ihr alle kennt mich ja ein bisschen, ich bin Bad Boy, ne klar, also Gesetze sind für mich eher so eine Art Vorschlag oder so. Da halte ich mich eigentlich dran, aber dass ich jetzt hier mal wegen dem gezeigten Mittelfinger Probleme kriege, pfi, meine Herren, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass das mein Stolper steigen wird in meiner steilen Bad Boy Karriere jetzt als für den Mittelfinger, das war ganz zu weit. Ich kann nicht so richtig glauben, dass wir da jetzt einfach so ein Negativbeispiel sind. Ja. Aber eigentlich auch ganz cool. Aber finde ich, vor allem wir repräsentieren halt das ganze Land Deutschland für die ehemals Deutschen aus Namibia oder die Namibia, ich weiß nicht, wie sie sich selber bezeichnen möchten, aber haben wir kein gutes Zeichen gemacht. Wahrscheinlich heißt es Namibia nicht Namibia. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Also, wie gesagt, Afrika hat genug Länder, 55, eins davon haben wir vergrault. Wir haben noch 54. Aber Gott sei Dank gibt es noch sehr viele Länder, in denen wir es besser machen können. Ja, ja, ja, ganz viele. Aber wir laufen ja auch nicht in allen. Noch nicht. Janik war ja ein Extrabeispiel jetzt. Noch nicht. Ich meine, ich glaube, in allen, in denen es noch einen deutschen Radiosender gibt, wollen wir rein. Wir wollen einfach rein. Wir müssen es wieder gut machen, wir müssen es bei anderen Radiosender besser stellen, aber ... Apropos Pornoseiten, weil mir ist neulich mein Laptop kaputt gegangen und dann habe ich mir, weil ich dann auch weg wollte von blödem Laptop, habe ich mir dann ein iPad geholt statt dem Laptop, so und der ging einfach nicht mehr, war nicht mehr zu reparieren und so. Und dann, kennt man das vielleicht, aber das iPad ist halt so ein wahnsinnig schönes, designtes, tolles, reines Gerät. Ja. Und dann hat man ja manchmal abends gewisse Bedürfnisse. Ja. Dann dimmt man das Zimmer. Oh ja, dann dimmt man die Küche, sein iPad zu haben. Man dimmt die Küche und dann wollte ich aber nicht das iPad benutzen. Es war zu gut, oder was? Es war zu neu und zu schön und zu rein. Es war so, es war so ein schönes, da steht ja auch hinten ja drauf, designt in California. Ja, ja, ja, nee, das fühlt sich falsch an, weil das ist ja auch … Es hat noch nie in die Tiefen des Internets geguckt. Ja. Und man wollte jetzt nicht derjenige sein, der diese Weite zeigt. Vor allem, ich finde, eine Tastatur bringt ja Distanz zwischen einem selbst und das Gerät. Exakt. Du hast eine Tastatur, so dass du deinem Botschafter und dann so, das soll ich jetzt dem Rechner sagen … Das iPad ist hey! Genau, das iPad ist so ein Hack. Das muss man direkt anfassen mit den Fingern, mit denen man, und dann, es ist halt so, man ist zu nah, man ist zu nah dran, es ist zu intim, es ist zu intim. Man muss sich erstmal kennenlernen. Der Bildschirm ist die Tastatur, du hast keine Distanz und es ist so ein umarmendes Gerät. Alles an dem Gerät sagt, berühr mich, hör auf Spaß mit mir, so und dann wollte ich das nicht. Und dann habe ich echt einen ganz alten Laptop. Der gute alte Lenovo von 2008. Nee, der alte Dell, der immer so, der will ich, so klingt, als würde es 30 Server fahren. Ja, wo man direkt in Stimmung kommt, wenn man einfach wuuuuh. Ja, man direkt auch ein bisschen geil wird und denkt, wow. Aber dann dachte ich, und habe ich echt viel langsamer, nur Nachteile, deutlich schlechtere Grafik, habe ich den hervorgekramt und habe den dann dafür benutzt. Der arme Alter, was hat der denn falsch gemacht? Nee, der hat schon alles gesehen. In seinem Leben, dass er jetzt als ein Schmutz-Laptop herhalten muss einfach. Mein Schmutz-Laptop. Ich habe ja auch manchmal ein bisschen Mitleid mit dem Inkognitofenster, weil ich sage mal, so viel streng geheimes CIA-Recherchen betreibe ich nicht. Nee, weil das ist so ein Agent. Primär Unterhaltung. Auch wie so ein unschuldiger Agent, der einfach nur dir helfen will und so. Ja genau, so, hey, ich gehör zu dir, Mann, ich sag keinem weiter. Was wollen wir machen, was machen wir heute? Ja, Pornhub, wieder Pornhub, ah. Oh Mann. Hier, wir haben das hier, oh Gott, das hier, nein, ach, lass mich in Ruhe. Und jetzt hast du einen Schmutz, jetzt hast du so einen Komplizen, so einen dreckigen Komplizen. Jetzt habe ich so einen Zweitlaptop. Es ist aber, es fühlt sich auch falsch an, und irgendwann weiß ich, dass ich erwachsen werden muss. Ja. Und wie jeder normale Mensch erwachsen auf seinem iPad-Pornos gemacht. Ja, ja. Aber fühlt es sich ein bisschen so wie Fremdgehen an, dass wenn sich das iPad und der Laptop irgendwann treffen und dann so, Moment mal, wer bist du? Vor allem, was liegt das iPad, was ich die letzten 20 Minuten gemacht habe, und dann hole ich das iPad wieder hervor. 20 Minuten? Naja, das wusste ich jetzt nicht. Das wusste ich jetzt nicht. Ich habe gedacht, was soll ich für eine Zahl sagen? Zu kurz wäre weird, Gesundheitsministerin Hackelt, was sagst du?
Fünf Minuten?
Naja, komm drauf.
Jesus Christ. Naja, ich meine, das meiste ist ja eh Suchprozess, von daher ist das.
Es kann aber auch tatsächlich kürzer sein, weiß ich ja nicht.
Man vergisst die Zeit.
Wenn die Rechnerlüftung angeht, dann ist die Zeit wie eine Zeitlupe.
Dann ist man in seinem eigenen Himmel.
20 Minuten macht ein echtes Spiel.
Herrlich. Wollen die Nachbarn hören dann jetzt immer schon? Ja, ja. Der alte Laptop wird wieder angeschmissen. Genau. Und auch. Und so, so Kinder, wir gehen jetzt alle mal in den Nebenraum. Warum müssen wir... Der Herr Tietze ist zu Hause. Warum? Oh Gott. Warum müssen wir jeden Abend für vierzig Minuten in den Nebenraum? Ja. Sorry an Yannick ganz kurz, du wirst die Folge wieder rechtfertigen müssen, einfach so. Nee, läuft der nicht mehr da. Ich würde mal behaupten, wir laufen da nicht mehr. Also wir haben ihn jetzt nicht gefragt, aber ich glaube nicht, dass da noch mal eine Folge. Vor allem wir haben, tatsächlich gab es auch noch ein anderes Nachspiel zu dieser Pufo-Hub-Folge, dass tatsächlich viele Leute uns geschrieben haben, um uns Pornoseiten zu empfehlen, aber hauptsächlich jetzt nicht irgendwie die gängigen, sondern so, sag ich mal, so independent progressive Pornoseiten, wo dann auch so richtig eine Geschichte erzählt wird und irgendwie dann auch, sag ich mal, für Pornos untypische Körper gezeigt werden und wo auch Rentner und so dabei sind und so. Also wirklich so progressives Gedankengut in Pornos und wir haben so die Gruppenpornos und so. Irgendwann kommt es daran, wie progressiv ist dann die Frage. Ja, und ich habe mir tatsächlich, ich habe mir da auch einen Probemonat geholt bei allem, weil ich dachte mir so, okay, vielleicht habe ich, ja, man sollte ja in allen Aspekten seines Lebens versuchen, auch einen Schritt nach vorne zu gehen. Und wenn es da einfach bessere, modernere Angebote gibt, warum nicht?
Sehr weird, sehr weird, tatsächlich.
Du kannst vorher auch keine Videos sehen.
Das heißt, du kaufst so ein bisschen blind.
Ja, es ist dann so ein bisschen...
Wie teuer ist denn sowas?
Ich habe nur einen Probemonat, wie gesagt, mir geholt.
Und der ist kostenlos.
Und dann hat man dann wirklich so super elaborierte Geschichten irgendwie,
wo dann irgendwie die zwei sich kennenlernen, Reiterhof, und dann sieht man die Pferde und so. Und ich denke mir so, du kannst jetzt nicht skippen, du bist jetzt extra hierher gekommen, du hast dir deinen Anzug angezogen, du willst jetzt ein besserer Mensch werden, du kannst nicht skippen. Also eine Kerze steht von dir in dem Laptop, im alten Laptop. Und dann hast du halt diese, und dann vor allem, ich sag mal, Pornos sind ja jetzt auch einfach ein Werkzeug, sag ich mal, um ein gewisses Ziel zu erreichen. Ja. Und dieser Aspekt wird in diesem Gefild manchmal so ein bisschen nebenan gelegt, weil dann kommt es zum Akt und es ist dann aber halt ultra modern geschnitten, irgendwie so super schnell geschnitten, mit ganz weirden Kamerasachen und dann so Blinklicht und dann träumt jemand irgendwo anders und du bist komplett in so einem David-Lynch-Film. Und dann war das, der Sex war nur ein Traum. Ja, genau. Und man denkt, jetzt ist man, das ist ja auch schwierig dann, weil du musst ja auch Porno-Management, also du musst ja auch dann zum richtigen Zeitpunkt am Höhepunkt sein. Was schwierig ist. Was schwierig ist, wenn es halt nur ein Traum war. Genau. Und dann fühlt man sich auch geschützt. Das war gar nicht echt. Und es war so David Lynch-mässig geschnitten und dann auch schlagartig woanders wieder. Und es war wirklich ganz schwer, da zu schauen. Man denkt dann, es hat schon einen Grund, warum Paul nur einfach keine Geschichte hat, schnell vorbei ist, fünf Minuten zu haben. Aber ich versuche mich zu bessern, aber vielen, vielen Dank für die ganzen Hinweise. Ich werde meine Mühe haben, mich da durchzukommen. Aber teilweise auch kreative Ideen, weil erst mal die Idee ist ja ganz gut, dass man irgendwie dann so realistischere, normalere Situationen zeigt, aber irgendwie, ich werde auf jeden Fall weiter auf der Hut bleiben und ich werde euch Sachen empfehlen können, falls ich wirklich dahinter stehe. Okay, weil so eine Seite würde ich auch mit dem iPad glaube ich mal anmachen. Ja, genau, das sind so iPad-Seiten. Ja, aber dann sind so shady Seiten, wo man, wo man denkt, ach ... Aber jetzt mal eine Frage, wo wir gerade bei Porno sind, mal eine Frage an dich. Glaubst du ... Das ist doch unser Take-away aus dem Abibia-Beitrag gerade eigentlich. Glaubst du, die Pornos, die du magst, glaubst du, dass die mir gefallen würden? Es wird aber sehr privat. Nein. Nee? Nein, ich glaube, die würden dir nicht gefallen. Okay, okay. Glaubst du, dass deine Pornos mir gefallen würden? Manche. Aber es ist alles interessant, weil man hat dann schon so ein bisschen das Gefühl, man hat da so seinen ganz eigenen Geschmack. Aber vielleicht können wir mal Pornos raussuchen, von denen wir denken,
dass der andere sie mögen könnte und dann tatsächlich uns die Schicken umzuschauen, ob es funktioniert. Ich wollte gleich mal einem Kumpel von mir meine fünf Lieblingspornos schicken. Ja? In so einem, komm ich sage, das ist eh alles gut Moment. Aber da kann man nicht ehrlich sein, oder? Kannst du da wirklich ehrlich sein? Man kann nicht ehrlich sein. Verwichste Klicks wurde gesagt.
Verwichste Klicks wurde gesagt.
Okay, alles klar, gut, das ist ein Gedanke. oder? Kann man da wirklich ehrlich sein? Man kann nicht ehrlich sein. Verwichste Klicks wurde gesagt. Verwichste Klicks wurde gesagt.
Okay, alles klar, gut, danke. Aber kann man da wirklich ehrlich sein?
Ist eine gute Frage, ich glaube nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube natürlich,
willst du, ich will weiterhin von dir geliebt werden, und du hast das Gefühl,
wenn ich dir meine Top-Five-Pornos sage, ist das vorbei.
Ist aber so ein Gefühl. Das Projekt ist dann auch gestorben.
Man hat das Gefühl, wenn jemand wüsste, welche Pornos sich anschauen, würde er mich hassen. Das ist einfach wirklich so ein Ding. Aber wir können es ja machen. Ja, kommt darauf an. Egal, egal, egal. Kommen wir darauf an. Aber können wir vielleicht mal machen. Vielleicht wird es unsere Beziehung auf eine neue Ebene heben. Ja, genau. Wie dass wir uns mal nackt sehen müssten eigentlich. Wir haben uns noch nie nackt gesehen. Wir haben tatsächlich, als wir angefangen haben mit diesen Live-Shows, dachten wir, okay, wir müssen eine Einheit sein auf der Bühne. Vor der ersten Live-Show war es mal einmal ein bisschen weird. Genau. Weil wir dachten, so jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt. Wir haben wirklich überlegt, ob wir uns nicht einfach gegenseitig mal nackt sehen sollten, einfach um so ein intimeres Gefühl zu bekommen, einfach um uns besser kennenzulernen. Wir haben beide bis jetzt das Angebot verneint. Ja, haltet mal die Augen offen, vielleicht kriegt ihr irgendwann mal eine Idee. Seid ihr uns gleich noch.
Aber eine Frage habe ich noch, Yannick. Ich weiß nicht, rufen wir mal kurz rein. Reinrufen ist jetzt mal kurz erlaubt. Und zwar, an was für eine Uhrzeit liefen wir? Jesus Christ. Oh, das ist eine gute Zeit! Ja, ja. Das ist eine gute Zeit. Genau, das macht mir Angst. Fakt für das. 16 Uhr, das heißt, da kann es sein, dass wir jetzt Teenagern, die unschuldigen Teenager, iPad-Teenagern, dann so Pornoseiten umgehen. Die Teenager, die sagen, oh, 15 Uhr, schnell das Radio einschalten. So funktionieren Teenager, Stefan. Kennst du das in der biblischen Welt? Ich kenne die Niederbibischen. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Naja, aber kann auch schon sein, dass da 15 Uhr Radio Zeit ist. Aber ganz kurz eine Frage noch, laufen wir da immer noch oder wurden wir abgesetzt? Ach Scheiße, dann ist es egal, nur für machen wir, wenn sie sagt, wisst ihr was, Fuck! Yes! Namibia sagt mir gar nichts! Aber diese Videoempfehlungen sind manchmal echt schwer, weil es gibt eine, es gibt eine Reihe von Kochvideos. Und zwar ist das so ein alter Italiener, vielleicht kennt ihr den, da hat es wahnsinnig viele Klicks, auf dem Kanal von Jamie Oliver. Und das ist so ein alter Italiener, der immer so ganz einfache italienische Gerichte macht und die sind supergeil. Und der hatte aber immer einen Freund, mit dem er dann zusammen gekocht hat. Und der ist irgendwann gestorben. Und dann, ein paar Monate später, hat er eine Folge gemacht, wo er das Lieblingsgericht von seinem Freund kocht. Und das sind Zitronennudeln. Supergeiles Rezept, so irgendwie so ein bisschen Knoblauch anbraten, irgendwie Chili rein und dann Nudeln rein und mit Zitrone und Zitronenschale drüber. Megageiles Rezept und das hat er gekocht, so in Andenken an seinen Kumpel, an seinen Freund so. Und das Problem ist, dass er in dieser Folge sehr emotional wird. Und am Ende hat er dann Essen und weint dann auch und denkt an seinen alten Kumpel und so. Und wenn du das Gericht guckst, guckst du dieses Video auch. Ja, und das Problem ist, ich wollte jetzt jemanden, der sich für die italienische Küche interessiert, dieses Video einfach so, hey, das ist ein Rezept, das könnte dir gefallen. Und einfach so, und dann die Zitronen-Tal drüber. Da hat er immer gesagt, tu für mich ein bisschen mehr drüber. Und die Bär ist einfach so. Das eine Mal, wo man Zwiebeln schneiden will. Ja, okay, cooles Rezept, aber wieder Typ, oder? Das ist so ein Problem, wenn du so eine lange Videoreihe hast. Und eines ist weird und du kannst es nicht erklären. Aber schaut euch das wieder mal an. Ich weiß nicht, wenn das nächste Video einfach wäre, so jetzt kommt Spaghetti Bolognese von meinem Opa. Ja, genau. In jeder Folge. Es gibt ein Seriet von meinem Opa. Ein sehr emotionaler Koch, der immer so ein Weinglas daneben hat. Und am Ende isst er halt die Zitronennudeln und sagt immer, I'm not sad, I'm not sad und heult halt, während er die Nudeln isst, was halt super merkwürdig anwirkt, wenn man einfach nur so, okay, jetzt den Knoblauch und dann die Chili nebenbei und er so heult halt. Was er auch nicht mitgedacht hat wahrscheinlich in dem Moment, ist, dass die Leute ja immer wieder angucken. Ja, genau. Und ich bin extrem schlecht im Kochen, ich muss ständig wieder und dann tun sie Öl, Öl, was Öl, wo ist das, Sonnenblumen, ist das in der Richtung, schaut euch dieses Video an, ihr könnt es bestimmt finden, einfach Pasta, Pasta al Limone oder irgend so was in der Richtung, mega geiles Rezept, Zitronenluden, aber wahnsinnig emotional, und ich wusste nicht, ob ich dieses Video jemandem schicken kann, so, Alter, guck dir das mal an, mega Rezept, weil am Ende heulen die alle rum, das ist einfach, es wird richtig runtergezogen. Ist so ein Geil, was man alles im Internet lernt, auch diese Masterclasses, finde ich ja mega, von denen ich auch ein paar gemacht habe immer gern. Du hast welche gegeben? Nee, Master gemacht habe, ich habe welche konsumiert, rezipiert, und jetzt gibt es aber auch so Serena Williams, lehrt Tennis. Ja, genau, ja. Und so ein Typ lehrt Schach, was ich noch verstehe, aufnahme. Ja. Aber dann singen, Christina Aguilera lehrte singen.en. Aber Serena Williams wollte ich mir echt was angucken, weil einfach schön vorm Rechner sitzen, Laptop auf, schön Lüftung auf Anschlag und dann einfach Tennis lernen. Ja, vor allem man kann sich ja in jeder Stadt einfach auch mal so einen Tennisplatz mieten und ich habe noch nirgendwo, und ich war seitdem oft Tennis spielen, um das herauszufinden, ob das jemand macht, nirgendwo hinten auf so einem Stuhl so ein Laptop gesehen, auf dem Serena Williams rüberbrüllt, was man machen soll. Ja, ein bisschen kräftiger noch! Einfach hau den Ball! Ist das denn die Idee, dass man sich damit dann in so eine Halle stellt und dann lässt man sich neben den Laptop und guckt, und dann hat man kurz Zeit, dann dasselbe auszuprobieren diese Übung, oder ist es ... Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich weiss nicht, dass es diese Art von Masterclass, das auch für Gaming gibt. Es gibt eine für Dota zum Beispiel, dass jemand erklärt, wie man Dota spielt. Richtig coole Idee. Mega. Ich glaube, das ist ein grosses Konzept, das noch sein könnte. Vielleicht wirst du auch eines Tages angefangen. Ich habe von Hans Zimmer die gemacht für Score, Writing Score. Also ich dachte, Hans Zimmer Snooker oder sowas. Einfach sowas. Wollen Sie eine Masterclass machen? Ja klar, gerne. Gelbe Kugel in rotes Loch und nee, Herr Zimmer. Der hat mir dann beigebracht, wenn man Filmmusik schreibt. Ja, und welchen Film hast du vertont? Keinen, aber ich könnte es. Ja? Ja, aber ich habe noch keine Angebote bekommen. Aber manche Masterclasses gehen sehr tief und auch ins Detail, wie man noch Angebote bekommt, wie man sich so den ersten Agenten besorgt, wie man die Karriere an den Start bekommt und so. Und da, es hat da gefehlt da. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt theoretisch einen Film perfekt komponieren. Aber niemand weiss das, du es kannst. Aber niemand, aber ich habe nicht gelernt, wie ich jetzt da hinkomme an den Punkt. Na ja, dann können Sie jetzt Leute hören, vielleicht, wenn ihr noch einen Film rumliegen habt und ihr sagt, ein bisschen trocken ohne Musik, einfach so neunzig Minuten lang Steppe und Leute. Aber es gibt, es gibt Hit-Record, heißt das, glaube ich, ist ein Projekt von Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
Und das Projekt besteht darin, dass Leute Filme machen können oder kleine Kurzfilme oder so coole Projekte, denen aber halt die Community fehlt. Zum Beispiel, weil sie keine Filmhochschule besucht haben und deswegen keine Cutter kennen, keine Filmkommunisten kennen und so.
Und diese Seite beruht einfach auf Schwarmintelligenz und die sagt dann, das ist meine Idee, mein Konzept, dann läst du dein Konzept hoch, wenn du ein Autor bist, kannst du auch schon ein Skript hochladen und dann suchst du dir halt Regisseur, Schauspieler, Leute, die die Filmmusik komponieren und so weiter, um am Ende dann einen gemeinsamen Film zu launchen. Und die würden sich dann auch die Credits teilen und wenn ein Oscar vergeben wird, dann bricht halt diese Seite ein Oscar und halt die Leute, die mitgemacht haben. Gut, du, bew dich da, kannst du die Filmmusik machen? Habe ich gemacht. Hast du wirklich gemacht? Ich habe für einen Horrorfilm, für den es nur einen Trailer gab bislang. Es gab einen Trailer für einen Horrorfilm, und für den habe ich Horrorfilmmusik komponiert und hingeschickt. Keine Resonanz. Kann man das mal? Null? Kann man das mal hören? Kannst du das mal irgendwie? Ich kann es mal hochladen. Ja? Würde ich echt schlafen.be ich mal die nächste Folge rein, das war sehr weird. Aber auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr da irgendwie Bock habt, zu kollaborieren, Hit-Record heißt die Seite, kann man sich, du kannst alles anklicken, was du machen willst gerne und dann einfach Leuten deine Sachen zur Verfügung stellen. Also falls ihr einen Horrorfilm mal gedreht habt in der achten Klasse oder so und den noch rumliegen hast, könnt ihr das machen. Wir haben ja tatsächlich im Musikunterricht Filme gedreht, weil wir über Filmmusik gelernt haben und dann sollte jede Gruppe einen eigenen Film drehen und da Musik drunter legen. Und tatsächlich war das ungefähr zu der Zeit, wo Ocean's Eleven super berühmt war und jeder hat die Ocean's Eleven Musik einfach unter seinen Videogrennen. Und es war eher so, der Schreibprozess war, welche Szene könnte das sein, wo Ocean's Eleven drunter passt und egal, so eine Telefonszene, zwei Leute telefonieren und dann dahinter die ganze Zeit. ... die ganze Zeit ... also war unerträglich. Unerträglich, aber auch saucool. War auch saucool, da war eine richtig schöne Zeit. Der Film, den ich damals gedreht habe, den finde ich leider nicht mehr. Ich weiß, dass den einer aus meiner Klasse hatte den, weil dann hat man sich so die DVD rumgereicht, so, will ich mir privat angucken, und dann haben wir uns leider aus den Augen verloren, und ich weiß nicht, ob der den noch hat, aber das wäre noch mein Ziel, den einst Tages noch zu. Weil er den Gena rückwärts gemacht hat und dann Ratschlag. Ja genau, er war so raus so, tschau, ich bin raus aus deinem Leben. Und damit war auch diese DVD weg. Sollte sie eines Tages wieder auftauchen, werde ich sie hochladen und sämtliche Gesichter meiner Freunde verfremden, mein Gesicht über die Gesichter aller meiner Freunde legen und dann wird's hochladen. Und dann passt vielleicht auch die Horrormusik wieder von dir. Ja, ich glaube, die passt. Ich glaube, die passt sowieso. Ja, gut. Mega geil. Ich finde es voll gut, dass ihr es geschafft habt, trotz Corona haben wir es geschafft. Ja, ich hoffe, ihr überlebt. Oder? Ja, wer Lust hat, seine Chance leicht zu erhöhen, sich mit Corona-Videos anzustecken, der kann jetzt noch im Nachhinein an Merchern kommen. Da sind wir noch und können Fotos machen. Und vor allem geil auch die Letzten, die nicht nur uns anfassen, sondern alle Leute, die uns davor auch angefasst haben. Also je weiter ihr hinten in der Schlange steht, desto mehr Leute habt ihr angefasst. Heute wird es lustig. Wir freuen uns noch, euch zu sehen, wenn ihr Bock habt, vorbeikommen. Vielen, vielen Dank fürs Kommen, haut rein, wir wünschen euch noch einen fantastischen Abend. Vielen Dank, das war's von uns, haut rein, Es war Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren!
Und er ist auf Führer, die die will! Vielen Dank!
Dankeschön! Vielen, vielen Dank, habt noch einen schönen Abend, macht's gut!